ously listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by
telephone I'll necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
27136 or email HCS lj. state. new
hampshire. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
Christina Dyer is the staff assisting us
and please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote I'm going to start by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please
State also state where there is anyone
whether there was anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
willing to call the RO
sure the committee list that I gave you
I don't pull it up give us just a second
here you got it
call
Howard I am here and in the committee
room Vice chair Judy Aaron
present have see pet Bixby
representative I am in my home office in
do New Hampshire and my son is uh
elsewhere in the house he probably won't
be awake before we're done he's still on
West Coast
time representative Kennedy here in the
committee room thank
you representative Davis here in the
committee room
representative
vinsky uh here in my living room in Keem
by myself thank you good morning good
morning representative
Highland yes I'm here in my home office
my husband's in the home but not in the
room thank you good
morning and representative
perz I'm here to and my home in Milford
um my husband is he's on office in the
basement thank you very much good
morning okay and any other Ena committee
members that are listening welcome and
welcome to all of you that are on the
public as well listening in we
appreciate it so we're going to start
today with House Bill
366 and soon as we're able I want to
pull up representative Avis who is the
chair of the uh Criminal Justice
committee I want to give him an
opportunity to talk with us about some
uh concerns and input that he has on the
bill I had asked him to uh review it and
provide us with h the thoughts that he
had from a criminal justice
stand so as soon as we're able we'll
bring him up
and have him give us his
thoughts think you
on good morning and thank you Mr
chairman good morning
welcome so just and I had a chance to
review that when I reviewed this um and
I will stick to just what the bill
attempts to do and not discuss the
underlying policy of
what the chapter itself does because
there's seems to be some due process
issues there but so my understanding is
that this bill intent is to expedite or
at least address the problem faced when
a person's
being charged with Animal Hoarding and
really what you need to figure out is
what to do with the
animals
during the potential
prosecution so what this as this
amendment or this bill has drafted what
I looked at
it is somewhat problematic at least from
a procedural persp perspective
so if a person is going to be considered
uh
incompetent that that person would need
to be the state would have to prove that
so that is something that they would
have to prove um they bear the burden by
a preponderance of the evidence that the
person's not competent St and that's a
constitutional right that any defendant
would have but in part of being deemed
in incompetent they have to show that
you cannot be uh your mental health
issue cannot be treated or
cured within a 12 month time period now
when I say mental health issue the it's
not a medical term it's a legal term you
know you can still have a mental health
issue but be competent to stand trials
so when it says cured it means you are
now competent to stand trial so that
requires a a in-depth evidentiary
hearing so this if that's the case the
and a person does submit to a mental
health evaluation even if they are
deemed to be incompetent but they can be
rehabilitated within let's say six
months it actually could delay the
process because the trial will will
essentially be the prosecution would
essentially be stayed and while that
person's receiving mental health
treatment so it actually could end up
slowing down the process if if which
would can be counterproductive to what
we're trying to accomplish here I also
looked at the language where it said
they would undergo a psychological or
psychiatric
evaluation I would would at least
reference RSA
135c and that section itself has to do
with involuntary someone who's
involuntarily confined because of a
mental health issue whether they're
going to harm
themselves or or another and the re what
I would reference in that section is
when a person is confined the court
orders that person to submit to a mental
health evaluation that's performed by a
psychiatrist and then that report from
is a report prepared by the psychiatrist
that's given to the judge to help
evaluate uh the the individual's mental
health status to make a determination of
now that determination in that scenario
would be to find the person but I think
in this case you have a a psychiatrist
would essentially be it would be a
recent mental health evaluation that
otherwise qualifies expert testim so it
would be at least in my opinion it puts
the court in the best position to make a
determination so you don't want to
follow the
135c procedure because that would
involve obviously the inv voluntary
confinement and that's a whole another
uh that wouldn't be applicable but I
think having that that standard where
the the court relies on a support for by
psychiatrist I I think you want to make
it consistent and have a psychiat
psychiatrist do it because they have
obviously uh education and and
Performing these type of mental health
evaluations in in their their doctors so
I mean that's what that puts the judge
in the best position I just I'm looking
at how this could be done the concern I
have is while all this is being done
it's it is a if it's a criminal case if
the person's found not guilty
I'm I'm not sure what happens to the
animals I I I I look at that as it needs
there was a charge there was an
order issued and I'm not sure where the
order would come from because in a think
of a domestic violence case where you
have the underlying criminal case
relating to the domestic violence charge
it could be a civil restraining order
it's separate it's a separate burden of
proof it's a separate hearing even
though that there's some
overlay um with the facts here there I'm
not recommending you have a separate
type of like restraining
order parallel that to domes of
violence but you're deprive someone's
being deprived of their property but and
you're having them go through this
mental health evaluation but I'm looking
at it while while that's
happening I'm not sure that
that's I I guess I my question is what
is the mental health evaluation trying
to solve here the Animal Hoarding is the
issue so
it might slow the case down but at the
same
time is the person going to get their
property back when the when it's all
sent done if they're found not guilty so
I'm not sure this bill as written
accomplishes its goal if the
person and H the other thing it's it can
be expensive to get a mental health
evaluation my understand is to have a an
evaluation by a doctor which would cost
if they're uninsured around $1,500 to
,000 when it's ordered by the court then
it's being there are psychiatrists that
can be I know it's under 135c there
psychiatrists that are appointed by the
court to uh conduct these evaluations
but again there's a cost to go with that
as well but I don't I guess I don't
understand what the evaluation is doing
other than
it's
really taking the their title way to a
property but suppose if they're deemed
incompetent then they're not going to
have the trial anyway but they're losing
some of their property but not all
they're losing their animals I just see
it's really it's it's a difficult
subject but I I don't see I see it as
such a clash between different areas of
laws and different that I don't I don't
know if this is going to accomplish the
goal and it actually might require to be
longer I don't know if that makes any
sense that was my evaluation of it and
then the underlying uh bill uh chapter
itself had some concerns in it in of
itself because again you can be deprived
of your property without probable
cause I want we don't we don't have to
go completely down that road but the
Fourth Amendment says probable caused
right in there so if you're deprived of
your property with the lower
standard I'm not sure that is
appropriate especially if you might not
get your property
back well now you understand some of the
questions we were wrestling with as a
committee which is part of the reason we
wanted to retain this get some input
from Criminal Justice I appreciate that
are you uh are you okay if I open it up
to questions from the committee for you
yes and and just for the the committee
members to understand and I hope hope
this representative forgives me for
throwing his name out there but the case
out of New Hampshire that discusses
incompetency uh involving a criminal
case
uh it came out in 2018
at that time representative Lynn was
sitting on the New Hampshire Supreme
Court so he would presumbly I presume he
would be very knowledgeable of that case
at least more than I am as he actually
uh he decided that case he's one of the
judges that concurred in the opinion
so thank you is there any uh questions
for chairman abis from the
committee know that you certainly
inspired me to look at things and read a
bit differently and uh we may be leaning
on you again because you gave me a lot
to chew on in area of Statute that I'm
not necessarily familiar with so I'll
have to go back and do a little more
reading if I could this reference if you
go
to uh line 28 where it says a person to
undergo a psychological or psychiatric
evaluation I would at least change that
a mental health
evaluation you know as described and
then I I can tell you the RSA
that is on point where involves the
evaluation by a psychiatrist so that's
135 C uh colon
40 is and again that's the involving inv
voluntary confinement you can somewhat
mirror that
language and where
it's discusses a report and then it
discusses what information you want in
that report specifically to be evaluated
by the um psychiatrist and then the
judge is not bound by what that report
says so it's it's really just a
recommendation obviously has some
influence the problem that creates is
that if it's adverse to a party not
people may want to challenge and that's
when they can get really expensive and
again we're while this is all happening
if they're gonna if it's challenged
there going to be hearings with multiple
Witnesses expert Witnesses clashing with
each other and meanwhile the animals are
kind of in going to be in limbo even
longer so I how long this process would
take to play
out to find an expert to just as a
lawyer when I've had to retain expert
Witnesses you you shop around you get to
execute a contract go over with your
your client make sure you get you want
to talk them make sure they're qualified
especially if this was me you know I'm
not I'm not me familiar with I'm not a
doctor so talking with an expert witness
it's going to take some time for myself
to get comfort with that person so that
can even take some time so I see this
hearing being two three months at a
minimum and then there's the issue
whether that person is an expert or not
but I I feel like if they're a
psychiatrist it shouldn't be a problem
but thank you looks like we have a
question from rep
Bixby yeah I just wanted to clarify in
terms of uh what the what the charge
would the potential charge would be um
animal cruelty um as a in terms of um
negligence uh and so the Animal Hoarding
would not be a charge um uh but I I
don't that's in some sense a picky point
but the idea behind the bill is if there
is
um if if someone if if the evidence on
the ground says that this person is is
um treating their animals negligently to
a degree that um it right it it it would
be considered cruelty then something
needs to be done about it and um and
then the question is uh is the
underlying cause of the
negligence uh a a willful act or is it a
uh or is it um the result of some sort
of mental
incompetence and uh what the bill is
trying to do is create a um a mechanism
so that the animals will be uh will end
up being treated
appropriately and but someone who is um
who is inapo treating their animals
inappro inappropriately because of uh a
mental health condition wouldn't
necessarily you know be should be uh
placed into the category of being a
criminal uh and uh and I know that this
is a um this is kind of what we're
struggling with because if they are not
considered a criminal then the taking
um then requiring them to get rid of
their animals becomes very tricky um the
legal basis for saying they shouldn't
have the animals is hard to make but at
the same time you don't want to give
someone a criminal record if they're
doing it because they AR aren't
competent so that's kind of what we're
struggling with and I don't know if you
have any um that that clarifies the
question so you could have give us some
more suggestions or if uh we're still
kind of stuck
muddling and thank you for the for the
question what what I was struggling with
myself is that so in order for the
animals to
be whether they're seat listen anytime
any type of property whether it's your
cell phone your
sunglasses your your jacket is taken
from you by the state by a government
actor it's a considered a seizure under
the Fourth Amendment now I understand in
a scenario like this there's somewhat of
a clear and inent danger to animals so
an officer feels it's necessary to act
especially in a situation where it says
they don't have time to get a court
order to act
so that I don't find anything egregious
about that policy but it doesn't it's
doesn't say probable cause under the
Fourth Amendment and then it goes on to
say even longer that if they can after
seven days they might not even file
charges so if it was such an urgency
once they take the animals into custody
or into that they should be trying to
file some type of charge or some type of
because they need an order at some point
they basically take your property and
then
if you don't come claim it you lose it
and I'm wondering what order does it say
that that they're allowed to maintain or
keep your property there is no court
order and there's no probable cause
standard stated in that in this section
what I was kind of throwing out there
was if you don't if the person's not
going to be charged
criminally in order to be deemed
incompetent to stand trial you wouldn't
deem someone incompetent to stand trial
unless they were being charged with a
criminal offense
even though I I understand logically it
might sound like a good idea well the
person's incompetent let's save
ourselves the trouble of uh going
through the you know the criminal
procedure here but if the person's not
being charged with anything there's no
need or Reason to ever deem a person
incompetent to stand trial so you kind
of have to be charged with something and
then if you're going to compel someone
to a mental health
evaluation if that's the circumstance it
would have to be by an order of the
court so for a court to issue an order
there has to be some open case attached
you know most court orders actually say
most every cour order I've ever seen
will have the docket number whether it's
a civil restraining order you know or
whether it's if it's a civil case you
know just simple personal injury case if
it's a court order dog number would be
on there if it's a criminal case same
same thing it will have court docket
number so if there's nothing pending in
a
court when you get a warrant that's
that's usually prior to there being any
criminal case but you have to again in
order to get a warrant and this actually
is something that came out uh not this
was literally I want to say in the last
week the Supreme Court United States
said that in order to seize Pro property
you need to have a warrant inside seize
it from inside the person to search
their
home you can't just simply do take go
inside some seize their property and do
that do it that way so it to me you need
if you do it with the warrant side
that's fine because you have you've
established under the law that probable
cause with going through a judge but
when you seize the property what are you
going to do with it are you going to
just keep
it you're getting the warrant because
there's some type of criminal activity
that you're alleged that police are
claim if there if they're not going to
prosecute the case they shouldn't be
it doesn't really make sense or for a
police officer to get a warrant because
they're they're getting it on the basis
of criminal activity you could go the
route of getting a civil order I guess
think of like a restraining order in a
domestic violence case but here it's a
lower burden of proof it's a civil in
nature in that case you can have a
domestic violence restraining order and
there never be an underlying criminal
case so that that that is something that
is is could happen and that to me
that's kind the only way I see this
being done if you don't want to
prosecute the person
but I guess setting up this whole
chapter this whole system I I don't know
obviously this is a problem that happens
but I'm I'm
wondering I don't see any other way of
doing it you need to have a court case
so that's that's kind of where I'm my
thought all right thank thank you rep
did you have a
question you know I do have some
questions but I think I'll save them
pronoun sorry I saw your hand yes all
right thank you uh rep
stable thank you U Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh directing
to representative Abus um it's it seems
like if we're concerned about the anim
animal as a
primary going down this Rabbit Hole of
um psychological evaluation and testing
and proof and warrant given the delays
that you have cited um don't we really
shouldn't we really be going in the
other direction of existing laws
regulations and statutes I mean we've
all seen incidents on the TV where
people have hoarded uh you know dozen or
more animals can't take care of them and
then uh Department comes in and um gets
a warrant removes the animals and
there's court case um on that subject
from other statutes so and and that's
the question don't we have adequate
statutes already to address the lack of
care to the animals uh and then deal
with the individual um in some other
fashion beyond
that it it's already animal cruelty is
already a crime and if there is a crime
being committed and there's prob cause
to believe that a crime is being
committed it's I guess in in with animal
cruelty it it could be a situation where
it's a crime in progress so if a police
officer has probable cause to arrest the
person they can arrest the person even
without the
warrant if they the warrant is to is one
way to go about it but when it comes to
seizing the property
I mean even if someone's arrested for an
unrelated offense to with the animals I
mean if you're going to arrest someone
and they're going to be you know they're
going to be held without bail for
example I mean you're going to have a
bunch of animals in the house that
aren't aren't AR attended to whether
they're farm animals or whatnot so I I
think the law does already address this
but it
doesn't the problem is is that while
this case is going on and would this
would have been even Amplified during
the covid-19
pandemic the trial is ongoing what's
what's going on with the animals and
this there's evidentiary reasons that
you need to if you're going to claim
negligence you
gotta you're gonna have to gather some
evidence in that route so I think going
getting a warrant and and doing the the
police investigation as they would
investigate any other offense I don't
see why you would deviate from that
because I think and I I get why we we
this we're trying to help as I'm going
animal everyone knows that and I'm open
about that but I'm just saying if you
create a carball on the law for these
for animals or this type of you know
which our property it gets a little
dicey on how you want yes I get protect
the animals but what do we need a case
or an order or something in place in
order to do that otherwise I I see a
serious du process
Pa thank you for that followup yes go
ahead
um yeah again um if if the primary focus
is is on the animals Animal Care uh
safety um the psychological aspect of
the uh
owner um Becomes of secondary importance
because time is of the essence when
there's abuse and you have to remedy it
stop it um and it seems like we've seen
cases where uh the state has come in and
and done ample work in to safety uh um
and and remedy of animal situations the
the um do you think that the um the bill
of
366 uh the definition of hoarding was
was adequate I I don't personally think
it was adequate didn't even give us a
number what constitutes hoarding um you
know people who can't take care of
themselves might be hoarding at one or
two animals people with some means might
uh be considered hoarding at uh half a
dozen you know what I mean it's too
variable and flexible U and do you think
that um definition of the bill um was
inadequate or could should be
amended so I didn't look into the
definition it of boing it it referenc
the diagnostic and statistical manual of
mental disorders it's it's not uncommon
when for a a law or a statute to to
reference a definition of that the
problem is they could change their
definition any time they would then be
changing your the
law while they if the look at this way
analogy we joke about this with my
someone names the planets Pluto they
Chang the definition of what a planet is
so what was a planet no longer was one
same thing and just're saying if they
changeed the if the diagnostic and
statistical manual mental disorder
changes the definition of Animal
Hoarding then so would the crime itself
would change so that that's the problem
with referencing that I I don't know how
they reference it and I would say you're
right some people can have 12 cats and
that be considered hoarding and some
some may not but as long as the animals
are being properly cared for I don't see
problem here my problem was how the
animals were being seized is that it
didn't
necessarily require a probable cause to
se so CH chairman ambus I'll step in
here a sec part of the reason we chose
that definition was upon the
recommendation of a an expert person
that we had testifying that came in and
U and there was a good definition
contained within there she's actually on
Q to speak right after you so perhaps
we'll defer that conversation if you're
okay with that rep staple until e Daisy
is speaking and you can ask her that
question as well and what I would
recommend just is rather than reference
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
the mental disorders is you you can take
what the definition is now and put that
in the RSA as opposed to just
referencing the manual because I'm just
saying if the manual changes its
definition ever so slightly essentially
our law our definition is also changing
without there being a legislative
process because sometimes you it may
change for whatever reason it just
that's just more of a matter of practice
than sure so I'm not sure it would be as
much of a problem in this case but just
that's the way I would do it trth thank
you uh rep Highland I see you're back
with your hand up you want to ask a
question now thank thank you uh thank
you for taking my question yeah I I
guess it might be appropriate to put
this out there now I just it's my
understanding that the the psych
eval would decide whether
um this would be criminal or mental you
know whether whether there would be
criminal charges or not but also when
you talked about before uh that they
had 12 months
to to become cured talked about that
term um it's my understanding that the
the point of of that would be to prevent
recidivism and that if this person could
be cured within that 12 months or
whatever the time frame might end up
being
if they can prove that they are able to
manage the animals within that space to
to become well or whatever where where
the parameters are um that they would be
able to get their animals back and then
not have legal repercussions but I might
be a misunderstanding and it might not
be appropriate time to bring that up but
I just want to put it out there thank
you so a criminal defendant has a
constitutional right to not be tried if
they are legally
comp and that's already the law so in
this case if the person you're saying
that if a person's deemed incompetent
this is what would happen but that's
means
that's competency to stand trial is a
legal not a medical concept
so you can
be that's what that's what I'm trying to
say it's a legal standard not a medical
standard so that's why the court is not
NE necessarily Bound by what the
psychiatrist or whoever performed the
mental health mental health evaluation
recommended it certainly carries some
weight the state has the burden of proof
to demonstrate the person um it is
competent to stand trial by a propond of
the evidence
so if in such a case where it there's an
evidential hearing must follow and the
defendant is entitled to present
evidence and cross examine any Witnesses
in the trial court M has to make a
specific finding U of fact and on the
record must identify the evidence in
which it based its decision
on and to and the reason why is that if
a person wants to appeal that decision
it needs to be a clear record whe of
whether that person is competent or not
now the 12mon time period is so when
they're determining if if if a person is
incompetent in part whatever conditions
that person has that that they're
relying on to find that person in
Conflict the court is making the
determination that that those conditions
will not be cured or improved upon
within a 12-month time period so that's
you can you may be temporarily
incompetent but from a legal concept you
would have to have something that is not
going to be able to reasonably be cured
or at least when I say cure to the point
that you are now confident to stand
trial within a 12- month time period
that's what the court is making a
determination it's
so it the it's the Supreme Court in New
Hampshire specifically did not they
actually said they they do not want the
psychiatrist of the mental health
evaluation report to be what controls
the finding because that is the role of
the Court not not the mental health
evaluate now again that holds a lot of
weight it is essentially for all intents
and purposes expert testimony or expert
evidence prepared by an expert but it's
just it's not per se this is the
recommendation there they're finding
that's the
quote thank you thank you uh rep
Bix yes um so I was
um I I was wondering in terms of uh the
definition and sort of citing uh the
definition uh for the d u the DSM for
the definition I was wondering if
there's any other place in law where the
DSM is cited for the definition or some
other third body uh that would be
creating a definition and I I think the
one the example that comes to mind would
be in terms of uh say um material
standards for building or that sort of
thing where there might be engineering
definition from an engineering or
organization and I'm wondering if
anything like that is put in statute or
uh sort of the reference uh rather than
having the text from that reference put
into
statute and thank you for your question
well I couldn't tell you how many times
it's happened but it happens all the
time where I my opinion is when because
we're dealing with a Criminal charge is
that you want to have a clear definition
written in the RSA and if you don't want
to even though you're re you're
essentially adopting a I would say a
reliable
definition and I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with the definition
provided I'm just saying that by if that
definition were to change by the third
party organization so would your
criminal uh definition of what what the
offense is so that's where my concern is
it comes to building
codes yes that happens all the time but
we're also dealing with civil type of
cases I'm just saying with a criminal
case it is important that a person's on
notice of what the charges
are and what is and is not know
ignorance and laws on defense but if the
definition is changing and it
happens it's little harder for someone
to follow than if it's whether it's done
by an act of legislation
I just would say for any type of
criminal case I would recommend in my my
opinion if you want to reference a
definition from a third party
organization rather than reference the
organization is that I would just
essentially cut and taste their
definition into the RSA and if they make
a change and and this body you know
supports that change it's worth doing it
but I would only say that for criminal
cases I wouldn't I think for building
codes uh you know
some uh Health codes that wouldn't
necessarily be as reasonable some of the
Civil
matters thank you uh representative Von
kinsky yes thank you Mr chair um so I'm
going to start this by saying I'm not
I'm not equating children and animals
here um but it seems like what we're
trying to do is determine if someone is
incompetent to care for
animals not you know whether that's
criminal or or not but is this similar
to when we try to determine if someone
is competent to care for children uh you
can be incompetent to care for a child
but it it could have nothing to do with
criminality it could be just you know
unable to physically lift a child or
whatever it is is
there again I'm not trying to equate
animals and children but is the process
similar enough to where we can lean on
what we do in in the case of children to
help guide us with what we're doing um
here with with caring for animals
and thank you for your question so when
it comes to Children you're dealing with
approprate and family court type of
issues and then there's although you
have constitutional interests in your
property it is a different
constitutional evaluation when it comes
to children so but I
read uh HB 366 the incompetency is
whether the person is confident stand
trial so you can
be you could be found I guess
incompetent um to care for your children
but still be competent to stand
trial so I don't think um those
necessarily are synonymous with each
other so I think here when you're
finding the person's in if the person's
in C to and trial they're in the stand
trial you don't need to codify that in
any any
RSA what this is doing is so if a person
is considered incompetent and trial what
do you do with the
animals the person's not being convicted
but you're essentially it would divest
the person of the title to their
property permanently and it would pass
on to family members or it says where
where that property would go but we're
essentially taking someone's property
from them and even let's say I was
deemed um incompetent to stand trial
and I'm and you took my my cats and gave
them to my brother now that person to
person that sounds very reasonable but I
own those animals I now they've been
taken from me and the legal interest in
those have been given to someone
else now I understand from an animal
cruelty from an animal cruelty point of
view I am 100% on board with that but
from a constitutional due process
perspective I've now lost my title to my
prop so I I look at that as a
concern and it just begs the question
how which direction do we want to
go I wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if
someone challenged that all the way up
to the Supreme Court and that that just
because someone will challenge a lot of
the Supreme Court does not mean that you
should comes up a lot at least in the
criminal justice Public Safety community
that it that does shouldn't mean you
shouldn't pass effect how you're going
to vote on this someone's just going to
challenge it I know um if you if you're
dealing with a large amount of animals
there's also a value side of it
especially if you're involved in
breeding animals so I I can see this
that being a
problem that even though the person
isn't is at the time they're incompetent
stand trial and just because you're
incompetent stand trial doesn't mean you
necessarily confident to care for an
anim again that they're somewhat
separate and distinct from each other so
I'm going to bring in thank you I'm
going to bring in um Eileen Daisy and
Stacy obber into the conversation here
because we're sort of getting into an
area where I think they have some some
valuable input that they could add so uh
Stacy did you want to come in and make a
comment
here thank you Mr chairman I really
appreciate uh your all of the
committee's time and attention to to
this and uh this has been very
informative to hear chair abbis uh with
his legal experience I wanted to just
thank rep Von plinsky for raising the
question about an evaluation as to
whether or not an individual is capable
of caring for an animal um and share
with you a I had a lengthy conversation
with a supervising judge at a mental
health court in Maryland who has drafted
manual for judges uh who are presiding
over an Animal Hoarding disorder case um
it's about 90 pages in length it's not
officially published but she's shared it
with me as well and I'm uh been
authorized to share it with you know any
lawmaker if it's of assistance but in a
case that she was uh presiding over that
individual was determined to be so
delusional that he was incompetent to
stand trial and other sections of the
New Hampshire animal cruelty statute I
do believe there's uh procedural
language around the temporary custody of
animals pending animal cruelty charges
um but there may be individuals where
charges have been brought and post
evaluation they are deemed competent to
stand trial but may be um incompetent at
caring for themselves or animals and uh
I think the real intent at least from
the American Catt Club standpoint was
to recognize that Animal Hoarding
disorder is not widely understood or
known and that there are on occasion
individuals who are repeatedly
prosecuted and
without access to mental health
treatment uh the literature suggests
that there is a 100% recidivism rate and
uh there was one case for instance that
I saw where a gentleman had been
prosecuted and 10 years later was being
prosecuted again because these are
individuals who are compulsively
collecting animals and if we don't
address the root cause of their behavior
we leave them and animals in this
Perpetual cycle of uh gross neglect so
thanks for letting me just share those
few Thoughts with regard to the purpose
really of the of the
legislation thank you uh eileene would
you like to jump in and add some to the
conversation yes I would uh thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you everyone for
for your wonderful feedback especially a
representative abis this has been highly
informative um some of the language that
we myself um and Stacy obber um we took
a look at this and we created a new
draft where we inserted instead of the
word or term Animal Hoarding hazardous
animal accumulation and the reason for
that is that uh psychological or mental
health valuation would determine if a
mental health issue actually exists and
to specify what type or types are
actually present instead of just jumping
to the conclusion that it's animal
horing just based off a quantity of of
animals that are in
question um and so I did want to just
reshare what that definition is because
I did hear the question earlier as to
how Animal Hoarding is actually defined
in the dsm5 which was published in 2013
and so Animal Hoarding does fall under
hoarding disorder just to clarify that
and it's as follows it's a failure to
provide minimal standards of Sanitation
space nutrition and veterinary care for
the animals there's also a presence of
the inability to recognize the adverse
effects on the welfare of the animals
the resident or residents residing in
the home and the home
environment this is coupled with the
presence of obsessive attempts to
accumulate or maintain a collection of
animals despite the deteriorating
conditions of the animals and the
environment and the lastly the person
presents with perhaps a denial or
minimization of evident problems
regarding the living conditions for the
person and the animals
um and I just want to go back to making
that distinction between hazardous
animal accumulation versus Animal
Hoarding is because we can also make
sure that through a psychological
evaluation is there perhaps a cognitive
impairment some sort of a physical death
deficit or is this accumulation of
animals related to some sort of
financial exploitation such as over
breeding and not related to a mental
health issue whatsoever of course the
forensic Mental Health Report would then
serve as expert testimony which would
provide the judge with um adequate um
next steps determining how the the
defendant and what the what the outcome
should be of the case um but again the
whole purpose of this is to really
explore whether or not there's a mental
health
concern here um and what should happen
next whether it's treatment or not I did
hear a question earlier from
representative Stapleton um regarding
the quantity or number of animals should
that be specified and in fact it
shouldn't um there is a huge um ex
actually a large resource of literature
related to Animal Hoarding and other
states have taken a look at this as well
that it can be incredibly problematic
specifying a number because let's say
for instance animal is defined as a
person not having the ability to care
properly for say 50 animals um but then
what happens when there's 49 it starts
to get rather subjective and and muddy
um and it really is the focus should be
around the quality of care not the
quantity of
care so I thank you all for your time I
just wanted to step in and share some of
my
thoughts right that down so bear with me
a
second is there uh any
questions the committee or or for E
Stacy or
or yes go ahead Jud yes so I'm wondering
would you are are you planning on
sharing that um those definitions and
the language of of the um I guess you
had a new draft of language that you
wanted to include in this statute for
this proposed
legislation and can you forward that
along to
us yes most certainly Stacy and I will
will do that okay great thank you for
your work on that it sounds really
really an
improvement rep Avis did you have a
question thank you Mr chairman it's more
a kind of an open-ending question for
everybody including the other two um
Witnesses is just
testified I I certainly appreciate that
if someone has a mental health uh issue
that
is basically they committing what we
Define criminal act as a that's actually
fueled by the mental health condition
they can't control the ACT uh in that
case it we really don't want that person
prosecuted because it's that's not
really we're not we're yes we're helping
the animals but not solving down problem
if this was a civil restraining order
type of situation I say that because
that's if it was a civil order that's
filed and part of that order you can
have a mental health evaluation that can
all be done without there being a
criminal offense and you that's really
that's up to I I would defer to this
committee on whether they want to do
that I think that would one put the
person in a position where they can
actually get or receive some type of
mental Health evaluation also they're
not going to be charged with a criminal
offense it's charges have to be filed
have to be brought but it also gives
that there some type of venue for there
to be some type of court order to least
justify everything that's that's
occurring but that keep in
mind the trick that you run into with
that and this is what the Supreme Court
case was about came out last week
but you need a warrant to get a warrant
that it the warrant is involved in a
criminal case not a civil case so that
puts the enforcement in somewhat of a
tight spot because now they can't they
can't seize the property without getting
a warrant but there's no criminal case
the way they get a warrant sometimes is
that they're saying you're violating the
Civil order but then by violating the
Civil
order you now have a criminal case
anyway
so I know that's
I I understand what everyone's trying to
do but it it's kind of goes around it
and what we really want to hold for is
for there to be appropriate discretion
when which cases are prosecute which
ones are not but even that can be um
subject to scrutiny so just ask a quick
question and then I'm gonna throw it
over to rep Dix So based on what you
just said representative abis if we if
this was to go as a civil order would
that would that still allow for the
seizure of the animals is where your
concern
is
well if there was a civil order in place
that would allow seizure of the animals
and there would have to be a burden in
elements that get said
order that would allow the animals to be
obviously put in a position where
they're no longer In Harm's Way it that
would also create a venue where the
person could get mental health be
ordered to submit to a mental health
evaluation and although their conduct
may be fall under a criminal statute
that person is not being charged with
any criminal offense I said earlier you
can have a domestic violence restraining
order without a criminal case to go
along with it it does it's very common
that that they run together but they
don't have to and it's it happens more
often than not that than where there is
no criminal P so I think if you went
that route that gives you the
opportunity to actually address some of
the concerns about not charging someone
because of really because a unfortunate
byproduct of their mental health issue
but I guess if the person doesn't comply
with the order and doesn't want to
surrender the animals because you can't
get a warrant now well I say you can't
it it's you not you don't have a search
warrant or a warrant to seize the
property you have a court order when you
enforce the order if they don't comply
with the order well that in and of
itself would be a criminal act you
without there being a penalty for
violating the order
the order is uh just a piece of paper
but then now you're dealing with someone
who now has they're getting arrest for
something else it's it's kind of
circular so you gotta kind of Juggle
that
in sure thank you uh
repic yeah this is actually kind of a
question for uh you rep Pearl as the
prime sponsor um so there there is the
the language of the bill as it exists
now seems to create create confusion
between incompetence to stand trial and
incompetence to care for animals and I
was wondering what uh whether your your
focus your main focus in in putting
together the bill was the idea of the
incompetence to care for the animals or
the incompetence to stand
trial I think it's more incompetence to
care for animals and uh it gets into
such a challenge ing area because again
it's it's not an area that um the
criminal justice side of it is certainly
not a strong Focus for me
and we certain I certainly worked with
uh with with Stacy and Elaine and a few
others in drafting this originally and I
I think my focus was more about care of
the animals and trying not to have these
folks prosecuted if you know and for
something that if we could avoid that if
possible and and find a pathway to get
these animals cared for properly I I
think I'm gonna actually pitch it over
to Stacy for a minute and let her weigh
in as well on what her thoughts were on
that thank you Mr chairman um I I agree
I think this was uh you know the initial
intent of the bill was to ensure that
the court had an awareness that this
mental health disorder existed and that
in fact it may be the root cause for the
gross NE neglect of animals of a
defendant brought before them um so I I
agree with you it may be in the rare
case that someone's disorder is so
significant uh as the Maryland judge
shared with me that they would be
determined uh delusional and incompetent
to even stand trial uh what I'd like to
understand from chair abis is whether or
not in terms of the Civil order approach
uh because agreed we'd like to avoid
criminal charges and instead try to
create a policy where we could use
carrots and sticks to have the
individual um get mental health
treatment um is there a difference
between a
warrant a Court warrant to seize in a
criminal case versus an administrative
warrant and uh for civil orders our
administr would an administrative
warrant allow the temporary custody of
animals so that they could be cared for
while the court was having the
individual evaluated and perhaps
deciding what criteria um this
individual would need to meet in order
to have the animals returned for
instance and thank you for your question
and when I answer this this this case
was L literally came out recently so
there may be difference of opinions on
it this this was L I want to say last
last seven days the Supreme Court came
out with this and in that case the
police searched a person's house they
had a civil order it was out of Rhode
Island it was uh it was a red flag order
and in those in Rhode Island my
understanding is only police officers
can file for those
orders and what happened is
they took the person they took the the
defendant or the respondent into custody
he wasn't there and they but they the
police told the person's wife that it
was he gave consent so to search the
house and then they searched the house
and seized property inside the house
even though the order says that a person
may have to surrender that property the
search warrant is different the search
warrant they can go
in they can go they have they have the
right to go go into the house and take
said property you know whether they're
it's voluntary or not that's they they
can knock on the door say we're coming
in to take to search for this that's it
if you resist they can the police can
keep carrying on with an order a civil
order they can't really they can't
really do
that it's it's
more hope for cooperation type of thing
but if you don't comply with the order
that is in and of itself a
crime now the crime is you're not
surrendering the animals so then then
the situation arises well they can get a
warrant to arrest you and it can kind of
go down that road but that doesn't solve
the problem of trying to avoid having a
criminal case more often my
understanding more often than not most
people and I don't have exact statistics
but when they whether it's a restraining
order or whatnot most people comply with
the order at least try to comp
because they know that's in of itself
another offense
so it would still help it wouldn't solve
your problem 100% but it
would I think it's better than going
that route at least if you can reduce
the charges by 60 70% that's still I
would say a
win okay just making some notes here
we're getting some great information
we're going to have to wrap up on this
particular bill here
shortly because I've got another one I
have to hear so excuse me another one we
have to work on question yeah so um I'm
not so uh a violation is considered a
civil offense not a um criminal offense
is that
correct or is that or does it depend
well thank you for your question so I'm
talking hyp pathetically speaking if
there was an order a a chapter in the in
the law for you to get a civil order to
address this every time I've seen
whether it's a harassment prevention
order uh domestic violence restraining
order I all these if so when it comes in
violing a court order let's say the
court orders you to produce your
driver's license and you just refuse to
refuse to do it you can be that case you
can be criminal contempt or it can be
civil contemp type of situation but when
it comes to violating a order of the
court of this it's a restraining order
my understanding of that is it is
generally G to be a criminal
charge the the Civil it's not going to
be a civil penalty now the penalty can
be a violation and it doesn't have to be
jail time but again the order without
there being a penalty for violing the
order the order has no key I've never
seen one I know last term we had uh the
proposed red flag bill it was HB 687
that had a provision in there uh and I
know the issue of the warrants and
everything came up in that conversation
well how do you get a warrant if there's
no crime um that was one of the few few
recommendations that was put in to an
amendment that addressed that the crime
is now violating the order so that would
have to be a criminal
offense so I I I guess what I'm
wondering is is there um is there a way
that
um the if the um if it if if the ca if
there is a criminal charge uh and and
certainly there under existing statute
if someone is uh neglecting their
animals to the point of Cruelty then uh
that is that is there is uh R you know
RSA U 68 688
6448 definitely has the criteria for
that being a criminal charge but if it
if that comes to trial uh is there a way
that a uh a judge would be able to
create a settlement that
would
uh end up um not having the person uh
you being
um having a criminal charge on their
record but at the same time uh being
able to uh M make sure that that person
does not um is not further able to have
animals in their
care so thank you for the question so
when it comes to a I guess a plea that's
can be entered uh my
experience is that if the defendant and
the state are an agreement
it 99 of 100 times it's getting approved
if not more than that by the court if
the state wants to agree to drop the
charges or you can have some type of
diversion program in place to avoid the
conviction once if that's the case and
the case is dropped or dismissed what
not that person should be eligible for
an analment if it's doesn't I I do
apologize I I know we had this last term
too I I forget if it actually happens
operational law or you have to actually
apply for the en um if you have to apply
for it then it's it's just some
administrative paperwork but once that
happens even though you're found not
guilty or the case has dropped it is
it's still that would not appear
anywhere and that's that's something
that I know when we had the analment
bills last term in uh criminal justice
Public Safety uh I think they all passed
on uh consent there wasn't we all
supported the only one we had any issue
with was um Senate Bill 311 so that we
don't need to get that that was well the
application of it
so so so there might be a mechanism for
um for the animals to be taken away from
someone who take can't take care of them
and that person end up not with a
criminal charge on their record under
existing
statute yes and as part of a disposition
person can agree to voluntarily
surrender the animals and I would think
that that would be persuasive I mean
some some may argue dur rest there
saying we'll drop the charges if you
give up your rights to you know your
property here so I can I can see some
some lawyers really uh frowning at that
but at the same time if if I'm
representing someone and it's it's a
tough case to beat and I said all you
got to do is give up the animals and
it's gone
in Li of jail time I I would I would re
I would tell them that that's your
choice but I would recommend giving up
the the title if that's what it takes so
the the courts so and criminal cases
don't like to get involved in
civil settlements per se because they're
they're separate and it gets a little
dicey when it comes like witness
intimidation or you're bribing a witness
I'll pay you this or you give me an
extra 10 grand I'll it's really has to
be careful how that is done because it
could be multiple felonies inadvertently
committed that's why having legal
council do it it's usually done in a way
that's part of a bigger scheme and if
it's approved by the court and the
person has Council I don't see that
being any duress or constitutional issue
there they they should have been
explained what they're giving up but
that can be done uh and but I don't
think that I'm not sure the judge has
the authority to to just simply say all
right I'm going to drop the case but you
got to give up your you're taking away
your rights to the animals I I I don't
think the Judge could just do that
finding
without any other
disposition thank you so I'm going to
wrap up here in the next excuse me next
couple of minutes on House Bill 366 is
there any uh last questions or comments
from anyone on the committee or any of
our panelists
all right seeing none I'm going to uh
going to close this portion of the work
session on hell Bill 366 but I want to
thank all of you this has been a great
conversation I probably have more pages
of notes from this than almost any other
Bill I've worked on I'm not sure I'll be
able to uh go back and understand and
digest them all but I'm G to need a
little time
to I really want to thank uh chairman
abis for coming in and spending so much
time with our committee because as you
can see is a very complicated bill for
us to handle sort of out of our area
anytime we're blending personal property
which is live would you know with the
policy of animal care and with criminal
justice it it can get a little dicey
certainly appreciate your expertise and
the time that you spent with us this
morning and uh I want to wish you luck I
know chairman abis is about to have a
new baby here like any moment so we we
wish you luck with that and hope all
goes well again thank you for coming on
with us
thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman by this time tomorrow um my
wife and I will have our our second
child should be born uh so we have a
young a young girl adding to the family
still no name picked out by there so all
right well congratulations and we
certainly hope the best as you go
through uh the birth of the child and
thank you for taking the time to come
and listen I want to thank Stacy and
eileene as well I appreciate you coming
on and spending the time with us looks
like we'll have some further
conversation about how we want to look
at the language of this bill so thank
you all right with that I'm going to
just take about a five minute recess
here and we'll resume at 11:20 and we'll
uh take up uh the work session on House
Bill
e
e e
okay welcome
back we're back from RE
and we will now begin the work session
on House Bill 585 an act allowing the
free payment of dog licenses fees for
the duration of the rabies vaccination
and reducing fines related there
too so the prime sponsor uh rep Lon was
not able to join us today because she
has committee work of Rome so we're
gonna kind to just have a conversation
about this bill and talk about some of
the things that we uh discussed back in
the uh during the
hearing there's some concerns that I had
about how this bill would impact the
department of a for
Revenue you
know there's some concerns that uh were
raised by some of the town or city
clerks I think we've probably got some
questions on this bill that we're not
necessarily going to be able to answer
today we can certainly talk about
the concerns that we have as a
committee but Bixby is there anything
that you'd like to I know you and I had
a conversation about this is there
anything that you'd like to start off
with and bring up some concerns that you
have yeah um I think uh well there there
are
two two concerns I have one is um that
uh I think that um we shouldn't be doing
anything with the current um
the the current uh schedule of fines for
um for not for not registering I think
th those fines are you know are just I
think that that issue we I don't think
we need to deal with at all um in terms
of the
um in terms of the registration period I
think that
uh that the the main impact of that is
going to be um you people can it would
be convenient for dog owners to only
have to register every uh three years
but I'm not sure how that's going to
impact Municipal clerks and uh it might
vary from um from town to town and City
to city as to whether it would how
workable that would be um and uh my
feeling is that uh if there are
um a number of Municipal clerks who
think that this would work for their
Community then we could set it up as
enabling legislation if the general
feeling among the municipal clerks is
that uh this is just more trouble than
it's worth I don't think that it uh
would make sense to pursue it
further yeah there's a list of questions
that my town clerk gave me
that don't know that we got all of them
answered
and not sure exactly how we do get all
of them
answered you know that that becomes the
challenge um there's certainly a lengthy
list that she gave
me so I'm trying to decide how we would
best proceed as a committee on on
getting some of these questions answered
I think maybe uh perhaps we could reach
out to the municipal Association and
they might be good resource for us or
perhaps a town clerk the clerk there is
a Clerk's Association as well perhaps
they would be a good
resource I think the department of a
probably needs to weigh in with some
thoughts on how this will affect their
[Music]
revenue there a couple that I had
anybody else in the committee that says
some thoughts on this and how they think
we should
proceed I think we're all kind of
looking at this Bill trying to decide uh
you know the concept is certainly
something that I'm interested in
seeing yeah I I think um it might be
good to get um input from the clerk's
Association and the municipal
Association and see if they would be in
favor of having this set up as a sort of
enabling
legislation and if there and if the
answer from uh those two associations is
no then I think that we could just um
not go forward with it if the if the
answer is yes then we can spend some
time figuring out how to make it work
appropriately another thought I had too
was perhaps doing keeping this in
committee for a little bit longer and
studying it a bit further because there
is to me some far-reaching ramifications
of this again I I have a list of about
eight questions that my clerk gave me
which probably is a pretty good starting
point with the clerk's Association to U
you know how this would all
work you know we get into the situation
where perhaps in the first year it's a
non-altered dog and then in year or two
the dog is altered and that would change
the Fe structure and there's just a lot
of moving parts to this when you go more
than one year I think it brings in some
different questions
right I I think um well um what would if
you could just uh let us know what the
questions that you uh your your clerk
gave you then maybe we can
um that would be useful sure I could
scan it but I've written all over it oh
oh well now can you H is it possible for
you just to just to read them out right
now and we of I I will do that all right
so these are the list of questions that
she provided what if the person has
multiple dogs with multiple rabies
expiration dates so they could have
three dogs that all expired in different
years what about puppies with only a
one-year rabies
booster that's don't always provide
rabies paperwork in a timely fashion how
would that impact this
bill if it's done for three years and
someone has three non-altered dogs nine
bucks each equaling $27 and the licenses
for three years times three they are
looking at
$90 roughly is that you know would that
be a burden that someone want to pay and
I guess that would be up to the person
that was deciding whether they wanted to
go for three years I mean I don't view
this as being mandatory I view this as
being U you know allowing them to do it
if they
choose uh what if a dog a non-altered
dog is altered after they pay for
three-year license will they be looking
for money back would there be a refund
policy what if the licensed dog dies
during the three-year period again will
they be looking for a
reimbursement clerks purchasing dog tags
how would they plan for that how many
would they
order that was the end of her question
the last was a statement which says it
appears that it may actually be more
work to change the current method of dog
licensing than to leave it as is
that was the input that IED from my
clerk and
la so I'm thinking perhaps we should uh
the next work session we have on this
bill we should invite ask Clerk's
Association the municipal Association
and the department of a to weigh in on
the various areas that would impact them
that be something agreeable to you as a
committee is there other people you'd
like to hear from
ah
head all right anybody else you'd like
to hear from on this obviously I think
reple on at some point would like to be
able to come back in and address the
committee when when she doesn't have a
conflict so I'll certainly uh work on
setting up another work
session I mean it's obvious this bill is
going to need some more work as well as
the last one um
I you know the last bill may need
significant work and that may take some
time I kind of want to get a feel for
what the subcommittee thought on this
bill and how they were
feeling anybody want to weigh in rep go
ahead yeah I was just curious if if this
is something that the municipalities and
everyone is really on board with would
we would we maybe start a new
program this is just I'm just kind of
brain I don't know if this is
appropriate but it seems to me that
maybe current the current setup can't
handle the three-year and that we would
have to almost implement it as if if you
get a new puppy you can start you can
start this three year now but if you
already have a dog in the system you
can't really apply to this right that's
kind of the way it is now am I
understanding that correctly sorry if
this is an inappropriate injection I'm
just a little
bit this is a not confused session it's
a great place to ask the question so
your thoughts start the program with a
new dog and let it track every three
years as it went through its R
cycle I mean again it feels like more
work but maybe it's an option I don't
know it could be an option but thanks
for taking my question yeah that down as
a
question yeah we we can certainly
develop a list of questions if we want
to I mean I can use the ones that I have
as a starting point that we could send
to the clerks and the municipal
Association and the department of act
for that matter and ask them to sort of
look at these questions and then look at
the bill come up with some some input
for us that's agreeable to all of
you certainly if there's other questions
you want uh you think of after we're
done with this just uh shoot me an email
and I'll put together a
list not sure when we'll get back on to
this because we're already on to May
20th it may be a while before we can get
back on the schedule again to get
another work session but we certainly
have plenty of time that was part of the
reason I wanted to look at these two
bills now and U get an opportunity to to
to look at them and get our thoughts
together anything further you want to
discuss on this
bill all right seeing none uh we do have
a presentation for the whole committee
coming at 1M from many of the different
faculty from un and looking forward to
that so I will put us in recess until 1M
and we'll return for the presentation
from un a we'll see you all
then
e
e e
you are live
oh dear
all right good afternoon everyone it is
uh 1 pm and I will bring the house
environment and agricultural committee
out of
recess and we have uh this afternoon a
very special program that uh members of
the UN staff and various organizations
related to them are going to bring us
some uh very good cool
presentations I'm really looking forward
to it we've got quite a list here of
people that are going to uh
speak so it will be I think a very
enlightening and uh afternoon for those
of you new to the committee who aren't
aware of what some of the different
departments in UNH do they'll U we'll be
bringing a lot of good information for
us just looking to see who we've got
signed on
so um I was going to start with uh
Anthony Davis the dean of Kula oh there
he is right there I see him now so we if
we can do that Anthony I'd like to bring
you up first and uh have you talk some
about you yourself and the programs that
go on there within your department so
welcome this is Anthony Davis the dean
of klsa that's great thank you very much
Mr chairman it's a pleasure to address
uh the committee this
afternoon beautiful afternoon that it is
and uh I have a short slideshow that I
will uh bring forward here and hopefully
that technology is cooperating with me
as we go so if that's the case you now
have a very uh UNH colored slide in
front of you we do
indeed um so as I mentioned it's a
pleasure to be here I'm Anthony Davis I
am the dean of the College of Life
Sciences and Agriculture
and uh I joined the University of New
Hampshire just last fall in September of
2020 I'm a Forester by training and I
actually grew up about six hours
Northeast of here in St John New
Brunswick Canada went to work for a tree
nursery up in uh Northern Ontario after
finishing my undergraduate degree uh
loved the work found that all I wanted
to know was more and more about how
trees grow and that pushed me into
Graduate School uh at Purdue University
in
Indiana after that I worked at the
University of uh Idaho uh running a tree
seedling program and then in a number of
uh administrative roles at the College
of Forestry at Oregon State University
so a really extensive uh broad set of
experiences in the land grant mission of
teaching research and service service
which I think are absolutely vital
towards uh sustaining our our rural
economies and ecosystems and and uh I'll
dive into that a little bit
more
um I get asked the question why is the
College of Life Sciences The Way It Is
What do you do as this college of Life
Sciences and agriculture why aren't you
a college of Agriculture and so building
that umbrella of what do we do the
College of Life Sciences and agriculture
champion Innovation and inclusion to
conduct engaged teaching research and
Outreach that addresses social and
natural challenges to achieve
sustainable lives and livelihoods we do
that at a scale that absolutely as the
flagship uh University for New Hampshire
impacts us here across the state we do
this in Partnership to lead in the
country and we do this for the world
both to bring experiences here and to
export our knowledge elsewhere we have
tremendous thought leadership in
developing new technologies in this
college and in helping those
Technologies be applied on our
agricultural lands in our Laboratories
uh in addressing challenges to how
people eat and what they eat and
Beyond I'm not going to read the list of
our undergraduate degrees some of you
are probably familiar with them but we
range from A to Z from animal science to
to zoology with uh many many stops in
between and we also operate the Thompson
School of applied sciences where we have
uh three three Associates degrees
programs a little bit different from
some of our University peers in that we
have both bachelor's degrees and uh
Associates degrees we have our applied
animal science our forest technology and
our Veterinary technology programs and
honestly these are programs that I think
are gerine to so many of the small
businesses and and family run operations
we see in New Hampshire but you can look
at the current enrollment which is the
number in parentheses and see that we
have to find a way to make these
programs accessible and affordable to
people who need the content of these
programs to keep them uh being sustained
moving
forward uh in terms of undergraduate
enrollment across the four departments
in the Thompson School uh you can see
we're we're relatively balanced in those
four uh departments our biggest being
molecular cellular and biomedical
Sciences that's likely not a surprise
when we think about the uh demands for
increasing stem Workforce uh whether
it's going into the uh production of
vaccines which we all uh appreciate so
much right now or uh for folks who are
entering into our health care
System um again seeing that small school
number here I think that's something
that just shows we're going to have to
figure out where do we go with this uh
this opportunity in the
future I pulled out some numbers that I
thought would be of particular interest
uh to to this committee and really just
to highlight the Hands-On experience
that our undergraduate students get and
that's that First Column that you'll see
internship and research
participation over 80% on average of our
students get a hands-on experience
either in a research lab or by doing an
internship during their undergraduate
experience here and when we look at our
post completion data what do people take
away as students who have come through
our programs we lead in those Hands-On
experiences they set people up to be
more successful in their jobs when they
start their jobs and to go on to be more
successful in research careers if they
happen to choose a research career and
so it's not really surprising that as we
move over to the other two columns we
see that uh collectively we're seeing
less than 10% of our graduat graduating
students having to look for work whether
they're choosing to go on to get more
advanced education or that they've taken
a job um that they're that they're
that's keeping them out of looking for
other work that to me is fundamental to
why we offer the mix of degrees that we
offer Student Success isn't just about
students completing a set number of
courses in a certain trajectory it's
about collecting the experiences along
the way that allow them to be gainfully
employed that allow them to further
themselves and hopefully come back to
lead in their communities in our
businesses uh as they move forward with
their
careers what part of what drew me to the
University of New Hampshire was the the
research that's conducted in the College
of Life Sciences and agriculture matters
this is really really fundamentally
important to us because we are a small
state we are a small University we have
to conduct research that's both uh
generating new knowledge and taking that
new knowledge and helping it be uh
transcended and applied and um we do
this at a pretty big scale we've seen
how the research that we have generates
new ideas informs change
it helps our businesses adapt it helps
us figure out what crops to grow where
to grow them and how and we do it at a
scale that's of about 15 million a year
for our college alone spending on
Research which is significant for a
university our
size and so uh it was actually exciting
this morning to see on nhpr the lead
story was on H novel tree syrups and
some research being conducted right here
out of the college and I just think
that's the kind of innovation that we
want to see where moves into uh a
tourist supporting industry where as
mentioned in this article restaurants
are excited about these or for us to be
better able to understand how things
like drought conditions could affect
something as vital to uh New Hampshire
as syrup production timing and
quantity we've also got a really strong
Workforce Development component some of
that we see in the internship programs
that I just mentioned as well as in
investing in our students and pushing
them to come up with their own ideas to
work with faculty to develop those and
then to partner with groups like UNH
Innovation and the entrepreneurship
Center to be able to take these ideas
forward whether you're a faculty member
or an undergraduate student or anyone in
between and we're poised for
growth uh you're likely aware of the
balding uh the Spalding biological
sciences initiative this is a a big step
forward for our University for our
College it puts about
18,000 uh square feet in
state-of-the-art research and teaching
space on the dock for two years from now
this is huge for us and this gives us
capacity to to have about 250 more
students each uh year in life sciences
and agriculture programs and we need
those graduates we need our stem
capacity to
expand and I know with some of my
colleagues on the call um it's great to
see them here and we are finding ways to
navigate Financial challenges and
partner with uh our peers like
Cooperative Extension and the school of
Marine Science and ocean engineering to
make strategic hires so that we're we're
taking everything we have right now and
leveraging to be able to get the best
possible return on investment that we
have uh uh that we can moving
forward so uh just to to wrap up briefly
uh you'll be hearing from our College a
lot more we just launched launched our
first uh uh print magazine which
actually I'll be sending a copy to each
uh of the members of the committee uh
soon after we finish our call today
we'll be pushing out more virtual uh
opportunities whether it's through
webinars and trainings or simply through
updates on on on Twitter or other
platforms and we're really excited to
get around to visit people on the farm
in the forest to be able to come and see
meet with people in their offices and
really set up that strategic direction
that we need to see to be able to make
sure that our college is addressing the
challenges that need to be addressed
here in New Hampshire now and into the
future so thank you for the opportunity
to speak and I will stop here and I I am
happy to uh take questions or pass along
to one of my
colleagues thank you very much for uh
the presentation you certainly uh piqu
my interest a bit uh there's several of
us on the committee who are maple Sur
producers so uh when you get into that
Arena you you certainly caught my
attention I actually had a question
myself for you uh so the vettech program
did did I understand you to say this 43
students in the Vette Tech program
that's correct there are current
currently 43 students in that program
wow do they uh primarily large animal
small animal or a mix of both uh
actually I will uh that's a great
question I don't think we have
specialization tracks in the vet Tech
program so this is a more General and I
can turn to my colleague Dave to
uh correct me if I misspoke there yeah
it does represent it does represent
across a broad range of large and small
animals I would say there's probably I
don't know what 70% of the time is on
smaller animals um but uh but but it
does span the full
range excellent it's ALS it's also one
of the other exciting dimensions of that
program is um a very
creative way that the faculty have been
working to launch a two plus two program
so we take the two-year program which is
which is an awesome program unto itself
but the students now have an option
where if they chose to continue on after
the two-year
degree they uh they've got their courses
set up in a way that they just continue
right along toward the four-year degree
and we have about um a quarter of the
students in the program choosing that
option and we're we're very excited
about that well that's great because
that's certainly uh very important to
the animal industry in New Hampshire to
have some vext in in the queue
absolutely all right I'll open it up to
the rest of the committee any other
questions representative Eric go ahead
yeah thank you and thank you so much
thank you so much for uh your
presentation is very very interesting
and uh I'm glad to see so much interest
I'm I'm interested to know though with
the student population that you're
serving do you uh track how many of
those students are coming from Farm
families or rural areas versus uh you
know more urban
environments that's a great question and
uh I haven't looked at that level of uh
granularity at the data but uh
representative eron I'd be happy to
follow up with you on that and I will
ask our data people uh what we have uh
access to it is Our intention moving
forward with our recruitment uh programs
and materials to be much more specific
in where we maintain a stronger
University College department or program
presence to be able to better connect
with prospective uh high school students
are post uh High School aged uh
potential students and have them really
be aware of the the rich career
opportunities that come from uh the
University of New Hampshire so that that
data I suspect does exist and I haven't
yet looked into it oh I really be
interested as a followup so you muted
you oh sorry oh you're on the Sor no um
so I'm really interested for to hear uh
that kind of uh data just a you know
matter of course as to where students
are coming from are they basically
following in their family footsteps are
they just something that's interesting
for them uh you know as a topic from
wanting to improve the environment or
contribute to um farming advances and
that kind of thing so thank you I hope
you will follow up with it I certainly
will thank you for the
question okay uh repola
sorry I'm fighting with my uh my mute
button thank you thank you for very much
for the presentation and also um thank
you for the additional information I
just want to piggyback on to rep eron's
question and uh my question is that I
just wonder in your if you can find this
out or if you just happen to have the
information uh what percentage of your
students uh might be from instate versus
out of state and the the second part to
that is if you if you do have sort of a
lower out of State rate that you would
like I just wondered your perspective on
if you feel like our you know the
tuition comparison from other states is
sort of a you know an obstacle to
overcome to attract people from out of
state thank you representative homo
that's a wonderful question and I think
you said I had four hours to speak about
this is
that so and we'll use every one of them
that's great I um I spent I spend a lot
of time that's the actually the level of
granularity of data that I've been
spending a lot of time looking at our
challenge is not in recruiting outof
State students to the University of New
Hampshire our challenge is in recruiting
instate students into our College into
our programs in the University of New
Hampshire and that's partly where that
idea of messaging comes out and being
able to build a better understanding of
how strong our programs are roughly uh
and I don't have the numbers right here
it's roughly
2third of our students I'm trying to see
if it's right over there roughly
two-thirds of our students uh uh maybe
three fifths of our students are out of
state so less than half are instate
students and that's important for us to
address because we see this in the
entire recruitment pipeline we don't get
as many instate students applying as I
believe programs of our quality should
see applying it's it's um
vital that we help our prospective
students see that the quality of
lecturers instructors uh professors
teaching assistant research
opportunities support services that you
have at the University of New Hampshire
actually exceed most of our peer
institutions we have excellent learning
and teaching opportunities for students
here we have to find a way to
communicate that with our communities
and uh across the state in order to
really boost that inate uh those instate
uh recruitment opportunities it will be
good for New Hampshire and it will be
good for society when we get to that
point thank you so much thank you hey
rep Murray has a question I do thank you
uh thank you Mr chair for taking my
question um and thank you um Megan can
you step into the microphone a little
bit more we having a hard time hearing
you sure is that better yep sorry about
better uh so thank you for taking my
question I was just going to ask what
you saw as potentially
a the relationship of that that uh less
than half of the students who are in
state what is detracting them from
remaining in state or are they going
elsewhere can you elaborate on that or
have you fleshed that out to any degree
uh thank you representative Marie for
the question it's I'd say we're early in
the fleshing out we need to do some more
um we need to do genuine market research
but from my own
um from the initial spaces and this is
something the university is really
seeking to address collectively not not
only in our college or our programs but
we likely need to be more engaged in
social media strategies and
communicating uh compelling stories of
both what the university experience
means and why the UNH University
experience can be a superior Superior
one not to a specific peer but for kind
of the generational change the last
person that should design a um
recruitment program for potential
undergrads is probably someone my age
it's it needs to be contemporary for the
likely students that we have coming in
and so I think as we are evolving and
we're looking into what does that how do
you do that um we need to get there
we've had some good response to a couple
of trial balloons that we've put out but
it is a an important strategy and the
the fundamental piece that I that I hope
is clear in this strategy is our degrees
are good ones so what we're actually
putting out there for people is a great
return on investment for them so it is
an investment in our next generation and
that's the important part of recruitment
when you have strong programs and
relatively lower enrollments we're not
chasing students to increase tuition
dollars we're chasing students to impact
our businesses our ecosystems our Farms
our forests our oceans in positive ways
because they'll be better served to do
it if they have a degree from us we
think I think than if they have it from
our peers so maybe in a year I can give
you a more comprehensive answer about
some things that worked or didn't that'd
be fantastic thank you thank you Dean
Davis I do enjoy that little bit of
Canadian accent that keeps sneaking in
there on
you all right we'll take one more more
question from representative Bixby and
then in the interest time we'll move on
go ahead uh so um I was wondering what
sort whether you have there are sort of
Cooperative connections between UNH uh
between csal researchers and uh New
Hampshire Farmers uh or New Hampshire
businesses where there's a a sort of a
Cooperative program in terms of
involving non-university people with the
University Research
that's a this is a thank you very much
representative Bix for the question
that's actually a great uh transitional
question too depending on which way we
go next but um my colleague Anton
Beckerman is associate Dean in our
College as well as the Director of the
New Hampshire agricultural experiment
station and in that particular direction
our the majority of our researchers at
the experiment station are are faculty
in this College college and there is
often a very tight connection between
our producers Network and research
Network one of the areas that we've been
uh seeking to expand and uh my
colleagues in Cooperative Extension led
by uh Ken L valy is in shared positions
between our two units that have an
extension component as well as a
teaching and small research component in
our College I think ideally one of the
end outcomes is we're better
engaged across the state through our
extension Network and connecting that
back both to our teaching and our
research because we're sharing
information more effectively and and we
all know that the uh hiring has been
difficult for for a decade or more even
at uh this University we have had more
vacancies emerge than we've had
Physicians come into uh replace them so
as we look to get creative to fill those
gaps those gaps aren't just designed to
get us to some baseline Staffing level
they're designed to maximize the impact
that our work has across the communities
and so our uh I as our college embarks
on a strategic planning process I think
what we'll see is a network where we're
engaged with small businesses we're
engaged with communities we have our
students in as as intermediaries going
back and forth taking information
bringing back questions we have advisers
sitting on our advisory boards who are
bringing forward questions that are
gerine to Maple Sy production or dairy
production or oyster production or soil
conservation or
uh prolonged routes all of those
questions I think we have some
individual networks our College will
take those and find a way to create them
into a pipeline where we have a really
strong two-way flow I think over the
next few years so I'd put it in the
emerging strengths bucket if I had to
assign it somewhere and also in the
tremendous opportunity for impact
bucket thank you well Dean co uh Dean
excuse me Dean Davis thank you for your
presentation I think with that we will
uh go next to uh director Anton
Beckerman from he is the director of the
New Hampshire agricultural experiment
station
welcome thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee I
will also share a presentation that I
had put together and hopefully you can
see that we can go ahead excellent well
thank you thank you again for inviting
me I I Anton Beckerman uh director of
your New Hampshire agricultural
experiment station and similar to Dr
Davis I am also relatively new to UNH
and to New Hampshire I spent the last 11
years at Montana State University uh
both as as an agricultural economics
faculty member and I also served as the
associate director of the Montana egg
experiment station um but I am very
excited to join the vibrant leadership
team here at un and to help facilitate
uh some of the most important science
and engagement Endeavors at least in my
opinion um that that we do here for for
many of our communities um a little bit
about how I view the role of the a
experiment station and while maybe most
of you likely know the station for
having a number of excellent research
farms and Dairy facil facilities and the
green houses that we have here in Durham
more importantly the station represents
one of the state's longest running
public research and development hubs for
agricultural food and natural resource
issues our goal is to strategically
Steward and maximize the return on the
federal and state public funds to help
answer questions that well don't have
answers quite yet uh our scientists
identify and work on solutions to
challenges that are maybe already
hampering the economic and societal
well-being of granite Staters but also
work on questions like how will New
Hampshire our region our nation our
world respond to the food and natural
resource and environmental challenges
that are five and 10 and 25 and 50 years
away and when those issues do become
salient in five or 10 or 25 or 50 years
it's the research from this experiment
station that will help provide those
science-based guidances to overcome
those challenges and that's really the
essence of what we do we're here to
provide that science based
guidance uh the way that we're
structured really reflects the
commitment to the langr mission that we
have it's the people it's the programs
it's the places the station brings
together those worldclass scientists
from across numerous disciplines to
address those locally inspired critical
questions and and to that stakeholder
question that's that's exactly we
include those stakeholders as those
members of of the people that are part
of our station that they're not just the
the folks who you know we provide that n
science too but those stakeholders help
us understand what are those problems
that we're facing now and that we may
face in 5 to 10 and 25 years a food the
natural resources Environmental Quality
in different ways they're important to
basically every single community in New
Hampshire and we consider every person
in the state our stakeholder and our
scientists take on Research that can
benefit a large number of people and try
to answer questions that you know maybe
too big or too risky for say a small
private Farm or a family business to
take on but in answering those questions
uh the outcomes can have these huge huge
long-term benefits that touch the many
diverse communities uh in our state and
region uh just to give you an idea of
kind of what we look like by the Numbers
uh as you can see we have over 50
research programs that our scientists uh
currently have on going and and they
really live up to the idea that the a
experiment station funding provides the
opportunity to test that initial that
that kernel of an idea maybe it's a
risky but really huge idea that can
solve many of the challenges that our
state and region face today and
something that may need to start and
maybe a lab and have some basic
knowledge be developed and then bring
that into a more applied setting uh that
can then be used to apply for those
external resources and build on those
ideas and expand and attract and train
the best PhD students and attract the
best faculty to really enforce that
positive Loop and relative to the stock
market you can see the a R&D that we
have and the return on that investment
relative to both the stock market and
many other states you know we provide
one heck of a big bang for the buck um
and that that $15 million that Anthony
that Dr Davis shared as our annual
expenditure well our researchers have
brought in in the past several years
close to $24 million that over the next
three to five years will contribute to
that $15
million annual expenditures that's over
a four nearly a
400% return on the investment that the
federal government and the state
government here in New Hampshire makes
in in uh in in our
research I I wish I wish that I could
show you everything that we do uh it's
really hard to describe all the impacts
that we make but here's just a few
highlights um as you can see there's
been a focus on and there still is a
focus on plant genetics which is much
more of a long-term uh concept and and
product there's production
uh and management which is medium and
shortterm production and management
resiliency to different risks like
product like like weather uncertainties
and Market uncertainties we are leading
in the fields of curbit development uh
those squashes and melons for New
England and organic Dairy research and
we look to the economic opportunities
that are growing in the state like the
aquaculture industry and and support
those Industries with three research I
looked at the recent statistics and New
Hampshire is the fastest growing state
in the nation in terms of aquacultural
production where are we going looking
forward where here's a really brief
summary of our ongoing scientific work
we see a real opportunity to become a
regional leader in local food system
security looking at things like
increased production capacity during
cooler months resiliency of our local
Supply chains which have been especially
tested during the pandemic producing
food that can actually be more
nutritious not just make more of it but
make better food and more nutritious
increasing small farms opportunities to
diversify and and reduce their input use
and cost and build strength against
Market uncertainties we have a great set
of researchers working on soil
microbiology and alternative pest weed
and insect management approaches and
also looking at numerous aspects of
forest man management and the existence
of value added products like that maple
syrup and maybe putting some of that
maple syrup into beer and making really
differentiate products that can bring
New Hampshire uh into the marketplace
and make people think hey uh this is
kind of unique and and cool um that
that's really just a a snapshot of the
really neat things that our scientists
are working on and the station helps
facilitate in terms of the research
Endeavors so let me end with that um and
I'll I'll end by reiterating that I
really appreciate the committee's
ongoing support of the experiment
station really excited about where we're
heading and the vibrancy that uh that
our scientists are bringing to the
experiment station work and really
making uh an impact by increasing the
direct communication and engagement
between our scientists and our
stakeholders across the state so thank
you very much I I'll stop sharing and uh
I'll be glad to take uh some questions
if uh you Mr chairman of the committee
have any thank you director Beckerman I
know you certainly hit two of my
favorite topics with maple syrup and
beer
and uh I am I happen to produce farm for
my day life and I've grown some of Dr
ly's curbit varieties over in the past
that he has grown especially uh in the
winter squash varieties and uh one
question I had you mentioned that you
were um worked in Montana previously so
what do you see for similarities or
differences between New Hampshire and
Montana in the in the research that you
do well Mr chairman members of committee
uh I did I driving a little bit around
the state uh in the past nine months I
did not see a lot of 10,000 acre wheat
Farms um so that was a bit different uh
it's you know one of the things that is
uh both similar is that even though
Montana is a much larger State the
population numbers are very similar uh
so that is certainly uh a challenge to
to some extent but also an opportunity
to think about the local food systems
that can emerge across the different
communities uh for which maybe
traditional Supply chains don't work and
I'm thinking primarily about maybe the
the Central and Northern parts of of the
state
um you know the other opportunity that
that I see a lot of is the ability to
diversify and the ability to look to
Alternative and um resilient management
practices that come around through
various research Endeavors to
protect producers and consumers from
those Market uncertainties um as as an
agricultural Economist I think a lot
about risk and uncertainty and the the
challenges that come about from that
because of of just not knowing what the
next year can bring and in food markets
that is a particularly important uh risk
factor um I I think that the value added
component is another aspect that was
emerging in Montana because the
commodity markets are you know wheat
markets became pretty weak in my time
there and a lot of producers were
thinking about well how do I overcome
these these challenges and and I think
the uh ability to diversify uh is
already highly ingrained in uh the small
uh Farm ethos here in New Hampshire and
New England but I think what we can
bring to the table is really structured
science-based knowledge of how to
diversify what are the best approaches
to managing both your production and
your economic aspects of the uh of of
your business how do we look at a
Statewide uh capability of bringing
together these separate perhaps
communities of local food producers in a
way that can Elevate all producers and
consumers in the state so I think
thinking about uh the state as a more
cohesive unit rather than communities
that are disparate and and separated um
I think that is a really important
similarity that that I think both States
um have a lot of opportunities uh to to
take
on thank you certainly diversification
in New Hampshire has been the key to
agriculture forever since you know since
we've been here but okay U thank you for
that I I appreciate the answer uh rep
Aaron thank you so much Mr chair and
thank you so much for this wonderful
presentation I know I certainly
appreciate all of the um uh updates that
I received from uh your your office
about different findings and uh new
things that you've discovered or awards
that you're winning and that kind of
thing but um I'm I've always been
curious as
to when you make certain discoveries or
you have certain results from the
experiments that you run or the you know
things that your uh students or
researchers are doing how does that
translate and how is that disseminated
to our farmers and to say backyard uh
you know
Growers uh do you offer certain classes
is there uh sort of how-to guides that
you share with everybody h how does your
discoveries get shared and
implemented Mr chairman representative
Aon thank you for the question uh that
that's a great question so there are two
aspects to our engagement and Outreach
efforts one of course is the more uh I
guess the tri tripart uh approach of the
of a l Grant University which is sort of
the the teaching uh aspect the
research uh and and the extension and
working with our extension Partners uh
that is something that is has
traditionally been done and working with
extension professionals uh and
collaborating collaborations between the
scientists and extension professionals
uh is is a really important Avenue and I
think uh Dr L Val will will speak to to
their efforts um in in disseminating
some of uh the signs that that our
researchers produce um so that's
certainly one approach is is using those
uh connections between our researchers
and our extension
colleagues uh another approach that I
think is something that I in Vision
really growing is the direct uh
communication between the scientists and
our stakeholders um we would we have
started a field day series that we've
been having for the past two months and
we would like to continue that on a
monthly basis we've had a field day that
was an AES an experiment station field
day on maple syrup production uh we've
had a a a a field day on seedless grape
variety production we're having a field
day on June 15th on Dairy production and
specifically colostrum and and the
benefits of of that um and as soon as we
are able to uh we will begin several
endeav to take our scientists on the
road on a much more frequent basis we
would really like to increase the access
between the communities around the state
and our scientists directly um and part
of that is going to be taking people
putting them in a car and and having us
go out there into the communities and
and speaking to them I don't think it's
uh reasonable to assume that every time
those communities are going to come to
Durham so that that is really a a big
um uh goal for for me to really bring uh
that component to the experiment station
and of course uh you know we've been
working on updating our website uh we
put all of our information on our web on
our website uh we have the monthly
newsletters our Communications manager
has really elevated the amount of
information that goes out there and we
really punch above our uh size in terms
of national
in getting notied by the USDA by the US
uh secretary of agriculture uh he often
gets briefs with New Hampshire a
experiment station stories included uh
in in those briefs so um we have uh we
have room for growth um in connecting
more directly but uh I think we have a
really solid foundation in in doing that
thank you
okay uh representative Bixby thank you
for taking my question so uh one issue
that has come through our committee um
in the last uh C two or three terms is
uh development of hemp as a uh crop in
New Hampshire and I was wondering if the
experiment station has anyone who's
working on that uh Mr chairman
representative Bixby uh thank you for
the question um coming from Montana hemp
is uh a well-known topic to me as as
they were one of the first states to
adopt state level rules on hemp
production there was a lot of uh
interest there um to my knowledge there
is no research happening on hemp right
now um that is something I I'm I'm not
sure of any researchers who may be
potentially interested in in hemp
production um so that's that's the short
answer I think the longer answer is uh
we are here to respond to to local
locally inspired issues that's that's
what we do and if there is an interest
and a need for us to look into hemp
research and to help science guide
production and management techniques I
would be very glad to facilitate that
discussion and and and have that
conversation so um that's not not an
answer or maybe a longer answer or a
convoluted answer but um yeah
that's where we are on
H okay thank you any other questions uh
rep
stable uh thank you Mr chair and uh
thank you for the lovely presentation um
I I noticed that there seems to be a a
growth in the coastal and aquaculture
area and um that uh that has a lot of
potential um for need and food products
and and so forth I was wondering how
much of that particular area is
attracting students from um out of state
from other areas that have an interest
in
that Mr chairman represent ston thank
you uh I I can't really speak to the
student aspect maybe I can defer that to
one of my colleagues either Dr Davis or
Dr Mortenson um I do know that the
aquaculture industry is uh growing it's
it's an important industry here in New
Hampshire uh both uh in on on the coast
and in the Inland parts of the State uh
we do have research on oysters on uh uh
finfish on sort of identifying pests in
aquacultural production identifying uh
barriers and challenges to and economic
barriers to agricultural production and
and I think that is uh an area of growth
especially within the context of doing
so in growing that industry in a
resilient way that will maintain the
tourism opportunities and the
environmental uh benefits that that our
state gets from uh the the various uh
water uh features that we have here um
so that perhaps uh that that will play
an emerging role if it isn't already
again in in attracting more students who
are interested in those areas um but I
can't speak directly to the question
about student
numbers thank you very much I I could
just chime in there this is Dave
Mortenson um the student interest is
High um and
they're one of this the spirit a spirit
that is being conveyed here with the
with the new leadership
in the college is um
Grassroots bubbling up of ideas for new
program areas there's a group of Faculty
that uh I along with the department
chair of the biology Department have
been having regular meetings and
discussions about the potential to
launch an aquaculture and sustainable
Fisheries um undergraduate program and
uh we've been doing cursory assessments
of student interest and we have a very
active aquaculture uh Club on campus
that um the kids are largely running
with two of our uh teacher extension
Specialists uh who work he you know very
much focused on aquaculture so so I I
it's I would imagine we will see an
increasing activity in this area on the
campus over the next couple of
years thank you for that additional
information okay thank you thank you
director Beckerman uh we appreciate your
presentation and I think that's a great
leading to uh bring up Professor David
mortensson he is the professor of
agroecology and Food
Systems go ahead Professor Morton
Professor mortson are you
muted sorry about that that's okay I
think we we got you now go ahead okay
great um yeah so what one of the things
that is
striking about
being here is it's it's an exciting
time uh because of a number of
things uh and one of those things that's
exciting is that we have a leadership
team that's new and uh a leadership team
that's
um excited about growing things and and
and listening to stakeholders as we as
we explore ways of growing programs for
our
students and programs for our students
that then go on to fill positions in the
state and in the region uh and I'm very
excited to be a part of that newer
member of team members I
arrived a little over two years ago um I
had been at Penn State and before that
at the University of
Nebraska uh the department that I chair
is the Department of Agriculture
nutrition and food systems and it was
through a restructuring that occurred uh
and that was completed in
2017 this department arose out of that
restructuring prior to that uh faculty
that were working in animal science
would have been in biology department
and faculty working in Plant Pathology
of you know diseases of crops would have
been working in the molecular and
cellular biology Department we now have
our faculty aggregated with focused
interest on agriculture nutrition and
Food Systems and we're very excited
about that along with the um the
aggregation of Faculty with shared
interest in their teaching and
research we um are excited to have a
greater number of our folks in a smaller
number of buildings so that we're
working in very close proximity to each
other in this in had it not been for co
uh the building that I'm sitting in
Kendall Hall would have been fully
occupied by a move of
extension uh
agriculturalists um to the third floor
of this building and the fourth floor
both floors fully renovated in the last
year um would be folks working on you
know animal and um plant agricultural
issues and the only reason we're not
fully occupied in the building are the
covid regulations and we're very excited
as those begin to relax uh that and
we're seeing people um coming into the
building um the other thing that was
already said by Dean Davis and I I just
I will just uh like to just emphasize
again um is this beautiful thing that's
happening here where we are
actively matching up positions sharing
the cost of those positions across the
College of Life Sciences and Agriculture
and our extension program and this is a
really good thing for the the question
uh that representative Aaron had about
um getting the results of the science
out to the stakeholders out to the
farmers um out to the food processors um
this will help us do that much better
and it helps us address uh establishing
and sustaining critical need of of folks
working in important areas for our state
and region and over the last last years
since since I arrived we've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
how do you create a a a sustainable vet
tech program how do you leverage off of
that cool vet tech program to form a two
plus two degree program where our
students have greater flexibility to
pursue uh exciting and interesting
degree options so our department has six
undergraduate
programs an applied animal science
program the the Thompson school program
um a four-year animal Science Program
which is our most rapidly growing
program in uh in the department and I
and I will say just just sometimes there
is
the thought that that the students
aren't coming from Farms or going back
to Farms our animal Science Program uh
now has 135 Majors um it's been
increasing about 15% a year over the
last three years and I would say half of
those students are coming from farms and
a good number of them are going back to
Farms mostly in this state or in
adjacent States we have a sustainable a
and food systems program human nutrition
and wellness and the equin
program
um again back to the to the question of
how it is that we get information out to
the state this this uh we've had a a
strange year as as I know your committee
has had a strange year um our seminar
which was always done in person was done
through Zoom
and we had more and more extension
Specialists from across the state
joining the seminar series each week
that we progressed into the spring
semester which was a blast because they
were joining and enriching the
conversations and just last Friday Elena
enen enan uh one of our master's degree
candidates in the department an
undergraduate graduate from our animal
science program and now an extension
specialist in Dairy livestock and forage
crops here's a case where Elena is
actually conducting research while also
working full-time with our extension
service so A beautiful example of
addressing a research problem in this
case expansion of beef production in the
state and and and surrounding states and
getting the word out directly uh you
know through um her programming that
she's doing at the state
level um our animal science program this
was taken the year before covid so the
kids are unmasked but this was something
that happened in our animal Arena the
animal Science Program um is extremely
active and as I was mentioning earlier a
lot of the students um have I mean their
their interest is to work with animals
for their career and want to do what I
would say most of them in the state and
region our students come from all
backgrounds rural um and urban I would I
don't have the statistics in front of me
but I would estimate that a greater
proportion are rural than Urban um and
they're they're a mixed Bunch um and I
just thought I'd give you a glimpse into
the background of a couple of them uh
today we have four commencement
functions for our six commence uh
undergraduate programs and tomorrow
evening is in-person commencement for
our kids uh this is Kyle Bloom with his
wife Sophie Kyle came to us um after um
getting out of the service having
completed two tours of Duty in IR Rock
he uh is a among a growing number of
veterans returning to school and Kyle um
has a farm and his wife Sophie have a
farm in the southeast part of the State
uh and um he's he's just been a gem to
have in our program and I think all of
our students have benefit they benefit
from one another much of our curriculum
is engaged scholarship meaning there's a
serious Hands-On component of this and
seeing the students working together
across the Vari backgrounds that they
come to our programs with it's it's just
a real joy for me and the other faculty
in the
program here's a group of students that
were working on um Hydroponics work that
is underway in the department and the
the the student with the blue stretchy
knit cap uh I asked Katherine who I just
saw at the commencement event before
getting on the zoom call here if she
would share a little bit about her plans
Katherine graduates
tomorrow and Katherine is going to be
joining one of our new split appointment
extension research faculty Anna
Wallingford to work on Pest Management
of vegetable crops and it's Katherine's
interest that uh through these engaged
scholarship activities that she's had
while she's been with us that she would
go on to do uh Outreach education in the
area of vegetables and Pest
Management so um the
45 or so majors in our department um and
uh this past year our department I'm
proud to report taught 179 courses to
3,400 of our UNH undergraduate students
but the department is live and well and
um we're excited as we uh are also
growing to the Future to fill out the
the role of our department and I'll end
there and be happy to answer any
questions you might have I I do also
want to say that it's a real pleasure to
be invited to speak with your committee
I um I haven't had this opportunity
since I've been to New Hampshire and I I
do appreciate the invitation well thank
you Professor we appreciate you coming
here today and talking with us so one of
the bills that we passed out of our
committee was a uh Bill studying the U
need for uh butchering services and
whatnot for uh the meat industry and
that may be something that Elena may be
interested in looking at and testifying
to that uh to that work committee when
it's developed um to talk about the
things she's found and what's holding
back the expanding the beef production
so that might be something of interest
you could mention to her I'm sure I'm
sure she would be because she's
conducted a uh uh a survey both of
processors and of producers and has
current in fact that was like half of
her seminar so she has really good data
on and and there is no question as
you're pointing out the bottl neck to
beef production in the state is the
processing capacity certainly well any
information she would like to send to
the committee we'd always be interested
in looking at and sure so with that I'll
go to representative
Bixby and um I think representative
Pearl was kind of reading my mind on
that one sorry so but so but I have a
slightly different angle on the question
which is that I was wondering if there
uh would be any room in the applied
animal science program for uh developing
a program to educate people who are
interested in becoming um butchers and
slaughterers uh to um so that we can
essentially have a homegrown Supply of
people who are going into that
business I I think that's a great idea
um we are just uh and I and I say it's
Ken lali's group that's been
spearheading the search but we've been
participating that college has on a food
safety position and that food safety
position which will be extension and um
some applied research and teaching
um has to do with uh both the safe
handling and processing of vegetables as
well as meat products so we're moving in
a direction to have greater capacity to
do that uh and I think that suggestion
is a great one
um and we definitely need to figure out
a way to grow that that capacity here in
the state and in the in the surrounding
states as well in fact this was
considered the bottleneck to meat
production in Pennsylvania as
well yeah from my understanding it's a
problem all across the
country yeah partic particularly the
smaller to small midsized operators are
but but it is across the country um yeah
thank you H representative Murray oh did
you have a follow represent I just had
to follow up on that I um I noticed that
the USDA was had a um a comment period
for uh for uh food chain um so food
supply chain issues and uh and grant
opportunities or you know where where
they might uh spend some of their create
some grant opportunities and I uh so the
uh there might be some federal money or
there might be a way of um pushing to
get some federal money to um help uh
develop that program
further yeah and again I uh Elena is
working in that space and um but but but
take come put together the training
program that's a great suggestion
yeah hey thank you representative Murray
yeah thank you Mr ter for taking my
question Professor Mortenson I had a
quick question um I have three really
young kiddos and two of whom have have
shown a particular interest in in really
understanding where their food comes
from and knowing that so can you speak
at all to the farm to school program in
New Hampshire or is that in your
wheelhouse or is that under somebody
else's director um
Direction yeah so I see that Stacy purlo
is on and this this is she and Aaron
hail this would be in their wheelhouse
um not not that it's not an interest of
the faculty in the department but I know
they're working on it actively and more
informed about that than I perfect okay
thank
you I don't know if you guys wanted to
say something but well we we uh perhaps
I can be part of Stacy's uh yep
presentation when she gets there so
thank you Professor mortensson we
appreciate uh your presentation and
taking our questions next we'll bring up
uh Robert Gibson who is in charge of the
veterinary lab
hello thank you let me um share my
screen here with
you do you see my screen we Canen go
ahead
okay here
okay thank you uh chairman Pearl and
committee members for inviting us today
and thank you for your service to the
state and on this committee I'm Robert
Gibson I'm the managing director of the
New Hampshire veterinary Diagnostic lab
and I am pleased to share with you some
background about the lab and the
essential services that we provide uh
for New
Hampshire the lab was created by an act
of uh legisl the legislature uh in a
statute in 1969
uh it was dedicated to our late State
veterinarian Dr Smith uh and we've been
providing essential diagnostic services
to New Hampshire and the region for over
50 years our mission statement
essentially comes from the statute which
defines our role as providing
Diagnostics in the detection of diseases
that impact animal and public health
there are a variety of stakeholders who
rely on our services and I'll provide uh
some examples in a moment
the organizational structure of our lab
is fairly typical for most Veterinary
diagnostic Labs uh Most states have
Veterinary diagnostic labs they are
typically located at land grant
universities or universities that have
veterinary schools and they generally
have a shared oversight and funding
structure from multiple sources so we
have the University of New Hampshire uh
where we are located here in Durham and
uh for the University we provide uh
teaching and training to students in in
various Majors including the preet
program uh so we have three boarded
Veterinary Pathologists who teach
courses and and do advising uh for the
college uh additionally we employ uh
students um uh as employees uh who get
hand on hands-on experience in the lab
and then we have uh the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture and uh they
provide some of our funding as well and
we report to them through the
commissioner and the state veterinarian
uh for and we'll talk more about their
role the stakeholder um services that we
provide to them and then the third
component is our fee for service
revenues and so the the prices that we
charge for certain testing to our
Veterinary clients and other uh
stakeholders and so it's it's the fee
for service revenue is about 50% of our
our budget and then the other funding
that we get from the University of New
Hampshire and Department of Agriculture
makes up the remainder
uh we are the largest uh Veterinary
Diagnostic lab in Northern New England
and by volume we are probably the
largest one uh in New England I said
Most states have Veterinary diagnostic
labs in New England um they're not as as
large again ours is probably the largest
Massachusetts doesn't have one so we
actually do a lot of testing for
Massachusetts and the diagnostic labs in
uh Maine and Vermont don't have
Veterinary Pathologists and so our
Pathologists do provide a lot of
services um to the region and that's
important because New England has lots
of small states close together we share
borders and you know what's happening in
one state is of relevance to our
neighboring states and so um animal and
public health uh is important for for
all of us um the testing that we do in
these other states uh also uh provides
additional Revenue to our lab to help
support the testing that we do for our
own State um the the structure where we
have um uh the fif for service the
university and the Department of
Agriculture it's it's a win-win for
everybody because each of the entities
on their own would have trouble
affording uh a lab of this nature and so
when everybody joins in again it's a
win-win for for everybody
involved um for stakeholders so I
mentioned the Department of Agriculture
we provide uh regulatory disease testing
for the state veterinarian and
Commissioner of Agriculture diseases
such as Aven influenza brucelosis
um New Hampshire was actually the first
state to be declared brucelosis free
back in 19 uh 63 U but declared free of
brucelosis by the USDA we also are
looking out for foreign animal diseases
AGR terrorism all of the the things that
would uh threatened uh New Hampshire
agriculture uh and the economy again for
the University of New Hampshire as one
of our key stakeholders I did mention
that on the academic side teaching and
uh advising for students student
employees
um getting hands-on experience um we
provide support for the agricultural
experiment station Farms doing
diagnostics for the dairies and such um
we also provide support to the animal
resource office on campus so uh any
research animals or studies that are
being done we we will provide um
pathology and disease testing in those
instances and we work closely with
Cooperative Extension uh and the
livestock agent U Specialists that are
in the field to educate producers so
that they know what services are
available uh from the lab for them uh
Veterinary Hospital clients
veterinarians so we have hundreds of
Veterinary clients around New Hampshire
around uh New England uh the New
Hampshire Veterinary Medical Association
um is a a big supporter of the lab they
have a standing committee um that uh
reviews what what the lab is is doing so
um our Veterinary clients and again that
fee for service component is is um
probably the largest part of our our
lab's
Revenue uh we do work for the New
Hampshire Fish and Game department uh
Wildlife disease Diagnostics uh that's a
large and growing area for our lab um
and Wildlife diseases are are critical
to animal and human health um we are
living all on the edge of of of the
wildlife and domestic uh interface as as
we um come in contact with with these uh
animals and um in addition to New
Hampshire fishing game we actually do
most of the diagnostic work for fishing
game departments in uh Maine Vermont and
Massachusetts as well um and we've done
some big studies on Canada links and
moose um and such uh um loons if a loon
dies on a New Hampshire Lake typically
comes to us for autopsy uh so w Wildlife
is is a very large and growing segment
of what we do um preservation agencies
science centers um any diagnostic needs
they have uh for the animals that they
care for we work closely with the New
Hampshire Public Health laboratory so we
um with rabies testing West virus Triple
E food safety uh disease outbreak
investigations uh we're part of the
laboratory response Network for biot
terrorism uh want to keep in mind that
the top biot terrorism agents according
to the CDC um such as brucelosis Taria
plague Anthrax these are all classic
animal diseases so Animal Health and
Human Health are are definitely linked
um zoonotic diseases the majority of
infectious diseases of people are
zoonotic they come from animals 75% of
all the newly emerging disease threats
that we read about and see in the news
these are all animal
diseases um we're part of the New
Hampshire arboviral task force uh again
we're on the lookout for emerging
diseases and and we are routinely
discovering and finding emerging
diseases whether it be diptheria in a
horse or carbapenam resistant ecoli in a
dog we are seeing um all of these
emerging diseases right here and uh um
we're we're making the diagnosis for
these uh I mentioned the New Hampshire
Veterinary Medical Association they're a
strong supporter of us and all of their
veterinarians their their membership uh
we do provide services too uh we also
serve the USDA Federal veterinarians in
our region uh with various Diagnostics
needed for different disease
investigations that they're doing in the
field I mentioned surrounding New
England states um for example
Massachusetts doesn't have a Diagnostic
lab so we do all the poultry testing for
the state of Massachusetts and that
brings in Revenue to our our state um so
we do a variety of State contracts with
our New England neighbors uh livestock
producers we all know how hard it is for
uh producer producers to get access to
large animal veterinarians and so we
have opened up some of our testing
directly to Farmers and producers to
help fill that Gap um whereas most of
our samples especially regulatory
testing and things like that have to
have a veterinarian submit the sample
there are certain tests that we can open
up for large animal uh producers um and
backyard poultry owners for
example
um commercial backyard poultry uh
another big segment of of the work that
we do we provide services to zoos
aquariums um uh we work with the Farm
Bureau for their membership and making
sure that they're aware of what services
the lab can provide um to help them
maintain healthy uh flocks and and
livestock we work with law enforcement
agencies so when you hear about abuse
neglect hoarding instances uh very often
uh those animals do come to our lab for
autopsy um and so both from New
Hampshire and out of state we do receive
um autopsy from log
enforcement um Marine Mammal stranding
um we do work with Marine strand uh
stranding agencies and so we do the
autopsies on uh marine mammals that come
up on New Hampshire beaches as well as
in Maine and uh sometimes in
Massachusetts too um previously it was
mentioned about aquaculture we do have a
growing segment of aquaculture clients
um so some of our Pathologists have uh
specialty training and experience in
aquaculture and the the very various
bacterial and V viral diseases that they
are plagued with um and so we
practically on a daily basis receive
specimens from various aquaculture uh
companies so it's a very U this is a
basic list of of of stakeholders it's a
very large group we very much function
under a on health umbrella which
includes uh animal health human health
environmental health uh because they are
all integral and they all uh are
important to each
other um this is just a a quick look at
uh our new facility um we built the lab
in 2015 I mentioned we've been on campus
for 50 years um this facility that we're
in now was built in
2015 um we're very happy very excited to
be here I have taken previous um uh Ena
committee on tours of the lab so um as
things settle out from Co I would love
to welcome you to the lab for a tour at
any time um that that's convenient for
you um I mentioned uh we have a lot of
student opportunities too some of the
the pictures there contain some of our
students so um that's the end of my my
presentation I would just say reach out
to me anytime uh this is your lab um and
we are here to serve you and uh uh
animal health public health and
agriculture in New Hampshire so thank
you I'll take any
questions thank you director Gibson that
certainly all those Services you perform
are essential to agriculture in New
Hampshire and we appreciate all that you
do I suspect as we get into the second
year of our session we may be able to
start to schedule some of these field
trips and we'll uh we'll definitely take
you up on that because I know personally
I'd love to go take a
tour okay so uh looks like uh
representative Bixby has a question so
go ahead thank you uh hi Rob last time
we were talking which I think was preco
um you mentioned that uh there was the
the number of um fee for service
opportunities that were you conceivably
out there would be um challenging to
meet with the current with basically the
current capital and uh
Personnel uh set available and uh the
possibility of
um possibly having the the possibility
of more funding uh in the short term
term might make it possible to have more
fee for service opportunities is that
still something that you're thinking
about um yes it's a that's a great great
question so the lab has consistently
grown over the years by fairly
significant levels uh which is exciting
it's great there's there's more and more
people using the lab um the challenge is
the the funding from the the the state
maintains fairly level and so um the
subsidy that would help support a
growing lab hasn't really kept up with
the demand and
so um what we have done to mitigate that
is invest in Automation and equipment to
make our our testing and everything more
efficient um but our staffing levels
have Fair really stayed the same and so
we've kind of reaching a bit of a
saturation point where the level of
growth gets harder to do without more
Staffing um however um with with Co and
some other funding opportunities that
are coming from the farm bill um A
Renewed um push to get the lab um some
levels of accreditation and membership
into Animal Health lab networks we are
exploring ways to perhaps get better
Federal funding that might allow us to
build the capacity that we're trying to
do um we're also exploring more
opportunities with some grants and have
had some success there so we are working
towards um building our capacity um it's
an ongoing discussion with the state um
with the commissioner um and probably
will come across your desk at some point
or other um that you know looking for
long-term stable funding for the
Diagnostic lab is is a an important
priority so um we are doing very well
and looking for ways to keep that
viability
going thank you uh representative
Kennedy thank you chair um so a couple
questions
uh Dr Gibson um I run a equin boarding
facility um close to the capital here
and um in my travels learning more and
more what about agricultural check
stations to help with the biocurity that
we have in the state um through the
pandemic um we've also seen a lot of
people getting interactive with outdoor
activities purchasing of animals
Trucking over the road we're seeing more
and more animals come in from the
Midwest where
we have different types of things like
strangles and um equin influenza the
herpes outbreak for example that we had
down in Florida is there better ways
that you guys have been working on to
try and help protect the um livestock
animals that we have here in the state
um and what would you suggest possibly
for us as a committee to help that so uh
excellent question the the concern of of
biocurity and the spread of disease
that's happening that between livestock
ecoin this is a is a concern we are
seeing more and more rescue animals as
as you're all aware rescue horses rescue
cats and dogs that are coming to us from
all different parts of the country with
them are coming all sorts of diseases
that are not from our region so we've
seen coides and a dog from Arizona
because we don't have that up here but
they're from Arizona we saw you know
diptheria and a rescue horse that came
up from South Carolina we we see
diseases popping up in in these animals
all the time so there's the issue of the
challenge of rescue animals um many of
these diseases are not necessarily even
reportable so they wouldn't be screened
for or tested for so um there are
regulatory diseases that are required
for transport and Interstate movement
and and sale things like the ecoin
Infectious anemia test we test 8,000
horses a year for that test uh these
regulatory test are largely controlled
through the state veterinarians office
and through the state you know the
statutes that that restrict movement um
as a Diagnostic lab we don't have a lot
of um say in in what's the effective
measure to to help reduce those risks um
we are here to provide and communicate
with our state vet the moment we have uh
what appears to be an outbreak or a a
situation that could pose a threat to
other animals uh and so we do report
regularly as a lab we're required to
report reportable diseases and diseases
of Public Health concern so we
communicate regularly with with Steve
Crawford's office but it would really be
under the jurisdiction of the State Vet
to um really decide if any um f future
legislation was going to help them in
their role in safeguarding the Import
and Export of of animals but so I know
he would be be working with you closely
on any of those questions thank you
thank you uh representative Murray yep
thank you Mr chair for taking my
question and um thank you so one of the
questions that I have um is what your
relationship is with tickborne illness
testing and the relationship of that
between zoonotic um diseases and humans
and animals actually I guess and the
intersectionality that you might have
with DHHS or anything like that this is
an issue that is
of great concern in my constituency and
I'm just curious to hear what your role
is sure so you're correct Vector born
disease transmission is certainly a huge
concern in our region whether it be
mosquitoes or ticks um and we are uh
from the diagnostic standpoint looking
out for these these types of diseases um
when it comes to
ticks specifically um that has tended to
be a really specialized test um really
relegated to certain labs and so
Connecticut was the lab kind of in our
region traditionally that would be
working with tix I would say though that
there is some uh renewed interest and
and efforts underway um in a joint um
effort between Maine Vermont and New
Hampshire us at un to enhance and create
um tick surveillance um and uh you know
the diagnosis of diseases Within These
ticks and so um that's a something that
has not been funded yet um it's it's in
the white paper stage and where we
through with Maine and Vermont are
looking for uh funding sources for that
so in the near future we may get more
involved um specifically with ticks but
we do um regularly diagnose the various
Vector born diseases and work closely
with the public health department um
with all of
that thank you I know uh from my own
personal experience I picked 20 of them
off my leg this morning from a short
Excursion out behind the farm so there's
a lot of them this year and I'm certain
that you're probably seeing a a
significant uptick no pun intended in
the amount of testing that you're
doing we are we we've been seeing we've
seen some livestock actually come in uh
deceased from uh overly burdened tick
loads and they were basically just bled
to death from from the levels of tick
and we are seeing these these ticks
migrating further and further north
where they traditionally haven't been
affecting livestock as much so just the
physical
bleeding that comes from the tick
feeding is actually causing really
significant pathology for for livestock
and so we were watching that closely too
I did you have something you wanted to
chime in yeah just just because it it is
such a new issue for the spring so uh
UNH extension we collaborate with um the
University of Massachusetts Amherst with
a program called tick report so over the
last couple of years we've provided
opportunities for residents to go
through our portal and have their ticks
tested for um one of several um human
born uh pathogens like Lyme disease Etc
so um we've been doing it but to uh
Rob's point I think it would be great to
have more inhouse
opportunities thank you representative
Aaron thank you Mr chair and thank you
um uh for your your presentation today
about the lab was ex really interesting
for me I'm interested to know H how how
is your fee structure developed I mean
is it you come up with uh uh what the
fees are for certain tests and
Diagnostics to be done and uh just an
additional question too is when somebody
sends something to your lab how do you
ensure that it's uh the specimen or the
dead animal or part of the dead animal
that's sent to you is sent in a way that
is um
biocure right representative Aaron thank
you so a couple of of of questions there
um our our fee schedule is set by our
lab um in across the country some fee
schedules for veterinary diagnostic labs
are set by the legislature uh in New
Hampshire the public health lab for
example their fees are set by the
legislature um our lab traditionally has
set our own fees uh which does allow uh
more flexibility um to make any changes
that are necessary um my view is that
having affordable pricing is part of
diagnostic stewardship and so if a
client cannot afford the test that's a
detriment to their animal their
livestock it's a potential detriment to
Public Health of of a disease that might
threaten humans as well and so we need
to be make these tests affordable um but
we also um need to cover our expenses
and um um also not trying to undercut um
private sector so um we are you know we
do market analyses and cost assessments
um and you know we're not trying to make
profits on it we're just trying to
provide a service that's affordable to
our
clients um
and your your your second part of the
question about biocurity for shipping of
specimens um we provide to our clients
um guidelines on how to properly package
and ship specimens and we do a lot of
effort into really trying to educate
them on that um our own staff when we
have to ship things out have to be
specially trained and certified and so
we maintain staff members that are
trained um both for packaging carefully
but also labeling appropriately for all
the do and iata um um Aviation
regulations that are required for
packaging and shipping so we we we do as
much as we can to educate um and for the
most part we have a fairly good um uh
track record for having things arrive
safely um and uncompromised and
certainly when we receive the specimen
we do everything that we can do for
quality assurance and to maintain
specimen Integrity throughout the
testing
process thank you appreciate that okay
well thank you director Gibson we
appreciate oh we have one more question
representative candidate go ahead thank
you chair uh one more quick question um
in the past for competition um when we
have collected blood samples for drug
testing um I've been informed that your
lab is not something that handles that
typically it get sent out to Vermont is
that something that your lab is
interested in taking on at some point in
time or is that
something
in so
again if you know if the need presents
and there there's a need for it in our
state we would certainly entertain and
look at uh ways to offer that service um
again when it comes to drug testing that
sort of Toxicology is is a fairly
specialized test and so um not all Labs
will will offer that and it's fairly
expensive uh the type of equipment that
you need to to be able to do that and so
it would take a fairly large investment
to be ready to do that um but certainly
if the demand was there we would um look
at possibilities to to do that thank
you okay thank you director Gibson we
appreciate it you've done a great job in
your presentation and answering our
questions next we will go to uh Marian
McCord she is the senior Vice Prost for
research economic engagement and
Outreach thank you Mr chair I don't have
a set of slides but I just wanted to um
give a welcome to all of you um I am the
senior Vice Provost for research
economic engagement and Outreach and our
office oversees all of the sponsored
program activities on campus um as well
as uh extension Cooperative Extension
professional development and training uh
external engagement in Outreach and uh
those programs managed by that unit
innovation commercialization and
Entrepreneurship um so it's a very large
unit and it's very outwardly focused um
so really looking at um as our mission
translating the uh research of the
university to make a social and economic
impact in New Hampshire so uh we're very
excited to uh be with you today uh Ken
La valy is vice proost in my unit and
he'll be talking to you a little bit
about um Cooperative Extension in a few
moments uh UNH is your state Flagship
University we're an R1 uh research
intensive University uh there are only
uh 130 R1 Institutes of higher education
in the United States so it's a pretty
Elite group um and that means that um
the the federal and state investments in
the the research work that we do um can
give really great benefit to the state
um I've listened with great interest to
the conversation and the questions um
I've been working with uh Rob Gibson and
uh Christine Bean at uh New Hampshire
DHHS to put together a team to do an
assessment of our uh surveillance
capacity in the State uh so we're
looking at um what kinds of capacity we
have to look for uh human animal uh
environmental toxins and and pathogens
uh as well as plants and um we're hoping
that by pulling together uh a network we
can build a Consortium that will uh give
better access to uh New Hampshire
residents to the expertise that we have
here uh in our combin through our
combined resources uh and will serve as
a a really a center of excellence uh for
surveillance and for resilience for the
State of New Hampshire um I arrived in
New Hampshire in February of
2020 with a a goal of of increasing our
research capacity here uh at UNH and uh
short weeks later my first official Act
was shedding down research operations
due to the covid uh pandemic uh and then
then re starting them again um one of my
biggest jobs has been to uh build a
covid testing program from the ground up
um you know we we don't have a college
of veterinary medicine or a public
health program or a a school of medicine
at UNH but we have a genome Center uh we
have great expertise at the vet
Diagnostic lab and in our other units
and by marshalling uh that Talent at you
we were able to stand up a covid Testing
Lab within 100 days from scratch and uh
tested about 4,000 people on our first
day of opening and so far we've tested
over
600,000 uh We've run over 600,000 tests
and uh we've been working with DHHS to
test uh jails uh school um I'm sorry
jails uh homeless shelters and long-term
care facilities for the state uh and
we're also now engaged in um in a a
state program for testing for camps and
uh Public Schools so we are really
trying to um extend the resources that
we have developed here uh to to U make
them available throughout New Hampshire
um so uh we are uh as a land grant
University you know again our our
mission is um to serve serve the public
and uh we're really excited to be making
an impact here in New Hampshire and uh
I'll be happy to take any questions that
you might have thank you very much I
appreciate the update You' provided I
didn't even realize that uh your work
existed at the college so thank you it's
new that was a great thing for me to
learn um representative Murray did you
have a
question I I did just generally speaking
but I I first wanted to say thank you
for all of the dedicated work I mean
setting something like that up in a 100
days is commendable and so our committee
thanks you for that but I did also just
want to ask if um the slide Decks that
we have been presented to U Mr chair
will we get copies of those
digitally I think we lost you there at
the end but I think you're asking for
copies from the presentations is that
correct yes please yes um I will
certainly uh put that out there to any
of the presenters if you'd like to
forward that on to the committee we we
would sure love to have
it any other questions for uh Vice
proost
mcord I think that worked out as a great
lead in because my next uh person I was
going to bring up was uh director Ken LA
valy from UNH extension thank you
representative Pearl and the rest of the
ENA committee uh it is always so nice to
get a chance to engage with you all and
uh representative Pearl I think knows I
grew up just down the road from his farm
in Penacook New Hampshire so uh you know
it's all it's always nice to uh um see
um other folks that were from the same
part of New Hampshire um I do have a
slide deck that I'm going to show you
and and I hope to keep it as brief as
possible let's see here you think I'd be
an expert at doing this at this point
from
beginning all right so I I fundamentally
just wanted to give for the new folks on
the environment nag committee um some
idea of who we are as UNH extension what
we do and then just a little bit of our
response to
covid-19 so who are we um we have
extension offices in all of the 10
counties we have professional education
campuses is in Manchester and Portsmouth
and one at UNH Manchester and I'll dig
in a little bit more about this in a in
a moment um UNH extension is about 150
people strong um it's very important
that we have more people in the field
than we do in administration and then we
do in Durham um so you can see here that
we have about
63% um of folks that are helping with
getting information out to communities
and with that I want to mention that we
I have two new phenomenal colleagues in
addition to Rob with Anton and Anthony
Davis I I think they truly appreciate
the uniqueness of the State of New
Hampshire and both genuinely want to
make a difference um to the A and
natural resource businesses and
communities around the state you may not
realize but Cooperative Extension
engages more than
150,000 residents per year in
face-to-face programs we learned very
quickly um through covid that we had
many millions over the last year
engaging in our online newly developed
content um from a return on investment
which is very important to me and to our
organization so the county contributes
about $2.9 million to Cooperative
Extension um the state through through
the usnh appropriation contributes about
7.6 million it's important to note that
uh the return on investment is high and
our extension
professionals um bring in an additional
$7.7
million um to leverage the county and
state contributions and this is
important because it truly allows us um
to be the size that we
are so I wanted to just briefly go over
our um five key program areas um
obviously food and agriculture is a very
important piece of what we do in
extension generally we want to provide
support to fruit and vegetable Dairy
livestock and ornamental Horticulture
Industries food safety for schools
restaurants and food producers and
practical advice for the home
Gardener it's also important that we
have safe and local food production and
smallscale agriculture continue to be
very high priorities for us in
particular we also provide soil testing
Plant Pathology and business planning it
was important during covid that we
maintained our ability to get out on the
sites work with the farms and make sure
we were doing the soil testing and plant
disease
diagnostic um needs so that uh we didn't
just leave in the face of covid um
another area that you might not be
familiar with is our ask UNH extension
so we have an 866 number 866 EXT grow we
have an online portal through ask UNH
extension and we also have a home
gardening podcast it's really funny the
home gardening podcast we just built out
during covid and we already have over
4,000
subscribers and it actually ranks in the
top five of all podcasts focused on home
gardening which was really surprising
ing um ask un is an important online um
gateway to home gardening Pest
Management Lawn Care questions food
safety Etc our 866 EXT grow number
Fields about 9,000 calls a year and that
is run by trained volunteers with expert
um content
reviewers you might have seen us on
Channel 11 with the grow at Green
segment that has also been an important
way for us to bring the intellectual
resources of the University out to
communities our natural resource program
area is also uh important we work
closely with our many state and federal
Partners uh we provide Forest
stewardship Wildlife Support Services to
both land owners and
municipalities uh land use and water
quality education you may be familiar
with the Lakes slay monitoring program
which is a partnership between the
College of life science and Agriculture
and extension for multiple decades um to
commercial fishermen and support for
trained volunteers working with their
communities to protect those natural
resources Youth and families uh
critically important you know for
extension we feel that positive Youth
Development is critical to the long-term
sustainability of business Society in
general and the economy of New Hampshire
and our staff provide lead leadership
for the 4 youth program in all 10
counties we educate K12 teachers provide
after school programming and specific
stem
education uh last count we were at more
than 25,000 youth participants per year
which is outstanding I'd like to see it
hire um we work with State Partners also
to provide substance misuse programs for
long-term pain management so Cooperative
Extension at our core is to be meeting
the needs of New Hampshire in general so
as those needs have evolved we've
increased our capacity to deliver
programs like substance misuse programs
Mental Health First Aid programs um and
also community and economic
development I'm very very excited to let
you all know that the uh University of
New Hampshire really does see the 4
program as its golden uh positive youth
development program and for the last I
think four years now we've provided a 4
merit scholarship this merit scholarship
is outstanding so every year from second
grade through graduating senior that an
individual is actively involved in 4 and
a club member they receive a
$500 merit scholarship per year at the
University of New Hampshire so if
someone is in for 10 years they will
receive
$5,000 per year that they go to the
University of New Hampshire New
Hampshire we're also allowing transfer
students so community college students
that come in after two years that have
been 4 participants in the state of New
Hampshire will also receive that
benefit our community economic
development program is really about
working with communities to
identify um what they need to encourage
Business Development sustain Business
Development and consider new ways of
kind of partnering with the natural
resources to bring more people to the
state of New
Hampshire um in particular extension is
working with about 2500 businesses each
year to do this in all
235 towns and cities of the State of New
Hampshire our fifth program area that
you may not be at all familiar with as
associated with UNH Cooperative
Extension is our professional
development and training arm this is a
fee for service Revenue driven program
that really also allows Cooperative
Extension to be the size that it is this
unit was formly the College of
continuing education and now we provide
non-credit program and certific programs
to more than 5,000 people each year in a
broad range of topics from storm water
management all the way to computer
science volunteers are our lifeblood and
in spite of covid or despite covid we
had over 4,000 volunteers this past year
reach an additional 53 53,000
individuals in the state over 14
volunteer programs uh the value of their
time
is more than just a number at 4.17
million they really are additional arms
out into communities bringing the
resources of the University of New
Hampshire into
towns um I want to provide in a couple
of examples of some of the programs we
do that I think relate to the
environment in a interest um so we have
a citizen Science Program citizen
science has has been um a growing area
of volunteerism for at least the last
decade and we have a very healthy
program at the University of New
Hampshire one particular program is the
natural resource program that hosts a
New Hampshire invasives Academy this is
a five-week course we adapted it to 100%
online we had 105 applicants for 40s
bases I'm really really excited to say
that representative Von blinsky
participated in our spring cohort and uh
after which he's already launched um
several garlic mustard volunteer days in
Keen
um additionally we had over 3,000
volunteers trained in covid safety
practices so despite um covid people
still wanted to find ways to volunteer
um in volunteer natural stewardship
programs so we educated them in safe
ways to do that following CDC guidance
and state
Guidance the final project I want to
bring up is called nature groupies now
nature groupies is a way to empower
multiple generations of outdoor
enthusiasts to volunteer again focused
on natural resource
stewardship um this is a phenomenal
program that really works with over 200
conservation organizations
and provides a One-Stop portal for an
individual who is interested in
volunteering um on a land care
environmental purpose um through a
network portal um this is a has been
incredibly successful again 200
different organizations are populating a
calendar that you can search based on
interest areas um and we're excited to
say that this is continuing to grow our
goal is to have over 20,000 volunteers
use this portal in the next five
years an example from our forest
industry so we support a $ 1.6 billion
direct impact um 7,000 jobs in the state
of New Hampshire in Forest
industry um particularly when we think
about Forest industry support we are
helping with
um how to
diversify um what to do with uh low
value Pine for
example um and figure out ways to uh
encourage
entrepreneurship in the low value wood
Market as well as train um and keep
licensed our commercial
Foresters I'll end by just giving a
couple overviews of the things I'm most
proud of that we've done during
co uh so we produced a farm products map
I think you all heard at the beginning
of covid that um there were rotting
produce and spoiling milk because there
were no place to bring it so we wanted
to connect the people producing the food
to the people that needed the food in
particular those who are food in Secure
we did the same thing with a local
seafood F finder um oysters you may not
know but their value is based on their
size and the most valuable oyster is
about two and a half inches so anything
more than that they start to lose value
so oyster Growers all of a sudden were
in a situation where they needed to sell
their product or they were going to lose
a great deal of
Revenue so what are we going to do
looking ahead we know that many people
have accessed our resources online but
first and foremost we a relationship
based in-person
program over the next few over the next
year we're going to continue to focus on
helping communities Ag and natural
resource businesses recover from
covid-19 we're going to continue to
build relationships with youth through
our 4 program and we're going to expand
our mental health healthy living and
opioid
programs thank you and I will take any
questions you might have
well thank you very much director Lali
that's great presentation I personally
am familiar with the services that
extension provides and has U George
Hamilton actually uh retired he has not
retired retiring the end of
June and we're all um holding our breath
because maybe he'll change his mind yeah
I know he's been threatening it for
quite a few years it'll be a huge
resource that the a community will lose
now you are absolutely correct and that
is a high priority position to replace
in our Hillsboro County Office certainly
we certainly won't replace him either
that will be a big shoes to Phil for
anyone who tries but we certainly
appreciate George and all the years of
service he's had in the ad community and
and to
extension you're a valuable resource for
those of us in the agricultural industry
we appreciate it thank you is there any
uh questions for director
lavali looks like you may get off easy
all
right well we thank you for your
presentation and uh we uh keep up the
good work we we certainly appreciate it
looking forward to seeing you in person
all right me too okay next we'll bring
up uh Stacy Perlo the programming
coordinator for the New Hampshire Farm
to school
program thank you thank you for having
me so again I'm Stacy Pura with the New
Hampshire Farm to school program uh New
Hampshire Farm to school is a program at
unh's sustainability Institute it's been
a home there since
2003 um I wanted to give you a little
bit of information about um what's
happening with schools across the state
on the local food procurement end of
things um some of this data is my own
that I've collected and some of the data
is from the USDA they do a a farm to
school census across the country every
few years uh the figures I have there
are a little bit old they're supposed to
be releasing new data this spring so uh
hopefully some of these numbers will
increase um so you can see on the right
the bar graph showing
uh the amount of dollars that schools
are spending on local food um some of
it's increasing like schools that are
purchasing nothing has gone down which
is great we want to see that um and and
some purchases um are going up into the
higher end but again this is still a
little bit old and we're not even going
to count this past school year because
it was uh really tough for schools to to
purchase from farm so so um and then
according to the USDA that is the
percentag is there that 77% of schools
participate somehow in farm to school
schools are purchasing $840,000 worth of
New Hampshire food um 70% of school
districts have a school garden and then
you can see the the top local food
purchases by schools so these are all
New Hampshire products um apples being
the favorite and and and easiest to
acquire and easiest to
serve um so we have a couple of other
programs uh that help support uh Farm
purchasing one is called New Hampshire
Harvest of the month so it's a year-long
seasonal calendar of of foods that are
grown in New Hampshire that schools can
acquire the program comes with classroom
activities geared toward elementary
schools it has school lunch friendly
recipes assoc iated with it um it's been
adopted by a lot of schools across the
state if you ever look at a school lunch
menu you might see these images there or
these Foods on the school lunch menu uh
so this month is mixed greens uh you may
see that on hopefully because they'll be
serving salads um on the menus we also
uh have a couple of Distributors that
are using it to promote um the foods to
two schools they sell like native Maine
uh uses it because they have a lot of
school customers in New Hampshire food
connects in Vermont uh which is a food
Hub but they also have New Hampshire
customers so they use it as a
promotional
tool um so it's pretty easy for schools
to adopt
this we also just last year finished up
an indigenous New Hampshire Harvest
calendar so it's a Four Season calendar
of foods that the abanaki people who
have lived and still live here would
have eaten um it's not necessarily meant
uh for schools to be able to go buy
these Foods because they can't they're
not commercially available um but it's
more of a classroom um program uh to
educate schools about uh the indigenous
people that that lived here and still
live here so you can see all the
different foods that are featured um um
some of them they certainly could get
like blueberries and and maple syrup and
cranberries and squash um so there's
recipes associated with it again
classroom
activities seasonal posters of all of
the
foods another project we're working on
right now is a local vegetable
processing project uh we receive some
grant funding to start this um schools
and institutions use lately processed
vegetables all the time it's a labor
saving product um they can just buy it
and use it they don't have to chop it up
wash it whatever it's just ready to go
so uh this is uh about trying to uh use
local products for that market uh so we
have this pilot project happening with a
farmer in The Lakes Region who is
supplying the carrots genuine local
which is a commercial kitchen in
Meredith that is making the carrot
sticks or right now carrot sticks and
they're going to move on to shredded
carrots and sliced carrots um the billup
food shed which is the purchasing
platform and the conquered school
district is is the buyer and so it's a
pilot project and we're we're trying to
work out what's going to work best what
are what's the price points that are
going to work best and hopefully expand
the offerings um and expand uh this
opportunity to other schools um in the
state so uh the next product up will be
a tomato sauce so we have to wait for
tomato season for
that so we also have a state uh Farm to
school network and we're working on a
farm to school reimbursement bill for
the state so basically asking the state
to fund this reimbursement Bill uh
meaning that for every three federal
dollars that a school spends on New
Hampshire grown food they would get a
dollar back from the state up to $1,200
per school so it's
really an investment in New Hampshire
Agriculture and an incentive for schools
to buy more Local
Foods and then a couple of other things
that are happening um the national
Center for appropriate technology along
with the national Farm to school network
uh have developed a a a training um it's
a train the trainer program um around
teaching people how to sell to the
school Market uh so this is going to
start later in the year um there's going
to be one in the Northeast the enat
Northeast office is in Kean New
Hampshire um and they participated in
putting this program together together
so um I hope to attend uh we hope that I
think someone from extension is going to
attend someone from the Department of Ed
maybe someone from the Department of egg
will go to this
training um and learn about the school
Market bring the program back and offer
some training to New Hampshire Farmers
on all about the school
market and uh the USDA Farm School grant
program um which has been around since I
think 2012
um we have three proposals from New
Hampshire this year that would support
um actually this incat training uh that
the department of Ed submitted so we
would be able to send people to the
training and then be able to support um
the training back in the state as well
as provide some stipend for Farmers to
participate in the
training um but since uh the Inception
of the grant program we've had
$500,000 come into the state to various
school districts and other entities that
have uh applied for the
grant um and then I also wanted just to
make you aware of the this is at the
federal level the Child Nutrition
reauthorization bill which is the bill
that funds the national school lunch
program it has to get reauthorized every
five years and this is one of those
years and so these are some of the
marker bills um that may or may not end
up in it but any of these would help
further support uh Farm to school in the
state and across the
country so that's what I have um and
happy to take any
questions thank you
Stacy any uh questions for for Stacy on
the farm to school representative Aaron
thank you Mr chair and thank you so much
uh Miss bro for your wonderful
presentation I'm interested to know um
how how many schools in New Hampshire
have access to uh green houses uh I I
know in my area we have um VI school
they have a a small garden out front um
and other schools are doing you know
other grow
programs but um I'm interested to know
if there are any schools that have
access to green houses um and and how do
they How do they go about funding those
as
well yeah that's that is a good question
I don't know off the top of my head
exactly how many schools have access to
green houses but I know uh some do uh
the newest one I think is in Pittsburgh
School District so way up there uh they
have a new Greenhouse um there's some in
the Lakes Region and on the Sea Coast um
so there are some and they've all been
funded in in different different ways
the communities and the schools that
wanted to do it may have done
fundraisers for it um they might have I
know a school in The Lakes Region uh
that uses uh Title One money for their
Farm to school program and they just put
up a greenhouse with the help of
extension um so there are there are some
I would say there are more just School
Gardens across the state than there are
green houses for those schools um and
again funding is in different ways they
could have funded it through grants or
or fundraising those are kind of
inexpensive um things to do followup
yeah and uh also in addition I'm
interested to
know to what extent any
corporations uh donate uh time materials
money whatever like ague or um Tractor
Supply or you know any of these other
companies that that deal with
agricultural um products
um I think so the ones that I'm aware of
and I'm not so familiar with egue or
Tractor Supply but I know like Lowe's
and Home Depot they have programs where
schools have gotten funding uh for
supplies for garden programs so like up
to $5,000 you can get all you need to
put in school Gardens and
more but I'm not as familiar with those
other businesses that you mentioned okay
thank you thank you uh representative
Murray uh yeah um Miss purlo um thank
you Mr chair and thank you Miss purlo
for taking my questions um so I'm
curious about the um intersectionality
with the Department of Education and
curriculum I know that you had mentioned
that um somewhere um and and can you
expand on that a little
bit so uh the the Department of
Education I worked with the nutrition
services department the most um because
they oversee the national school school
lunch program um and they are the
department is very Farm to school
friendly so we've collaborated on
projects um they created a their own
Harvest of the month program for um
early childhood education
programs um so I'm not so much on the
curriculum end but on the food service
and school food end of it okay thank you
very
much any other questions for uh Miss
purlo
all right seeing none we thank you very
much for your presentation learned a lot
next we'll have up Aaron hail from the
New Hampshire Food
Alliance
wonderful thank you I'm gonna share my
screen as
well can you all see okay we got it go
ahead all right great so thank you again
for the opportunity to share some of our
work with you um the New Hampshire Food
Alliance is an initiative with the
sustainability Institute we are a
Statewide food system Network so here
today it's been wonderful to hear a lot
about what my colleagues at UNH are
doing um we've talked a lot about
stakeholders and engaging with the
community and that's really a lot of
what we do um with the Food Alliance so
here this slide here just shows some of
our many partners that we work with
across the the state you can see that um
we work with both Statewide
organizations that work directly with
Farmers like extension as well as more
Regional organizations to try to connect
all of the groups um that are working to
strengthen the New Hampshire food system
across New Hampshire um our Network
leadership team is the group of people
that provide strategic Direction um for
our Network and you can see again here
we've got Heidi Barker from UNH
Cooperative EXT Ion on that team
Charlene Anderson from the New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund again we have a
breadth of leaders that are helping to
kind of keep an eye on what's Happening
across the food system and figure out
how we can collaborate um again to help
strengthen um strengthen our food system
so again our main focus is on connecting
all of these groups um across the state
and um to make sure that we are learning
together and figuring out ways that we
can work better together and we focus on
these six um these six areas increasing
Farmland conservation and access
supporting local Farm fish and food
businesses encouraging eaters to choose
local improving food security and local
food access responding and adapting to
climate change and then promoting racial
equity in our food system and again
these are areas that our Network
Partners have said are important to them
and these are the areas that they want
to collaborate um to collaborate in so
I'm going to give you some examples of
collaborative initiatives that have come
out of our work together um I don't know
if any of you have heard about the New
Hampshire feeding New Hampshire project
this developed just last spring and
formed as a result of our weekly
meetings that we started organizing when
everything shut down because of covid we
were organizing weekly and then
bi-weekly calls with our Network
Partners who are trying to figure out
how do we a support a lot of people who'
have now lost their jobs and are facing
food insecurity and also a lot of our
local producers that were having to
figure out ways to quickly pivot and
find new markets and new customers and
so we work together with the New
Hampshire Food Bank the Farm Bureau and
also noan New Hampshire to start this
program um that essentially delivered um
uh money into the hands of our New
Hampshire producers um by giving food
pantries the ability to purchase
directly from our local
Growers um this program is continuing
and is continuing to grow um this summer
we're going to be um there's going to be
$200,000 allocated to New Hampshire Food
Bank pant pantries to purchase local
produce um another project that
developed this last year and was the
result of a um USDA specialty crop blant
crop block grant um was the development
of a New Hampshire food Hub Network so
again um we have a growing number of
food hubs across the state which are um
groups that are helping to aggregate
local products and deliver them directly
to to customers or
institutions and one of the the issues
or barriers to Growing this market for
local food has been the ability to reach
different parts of the state and so the
network is now working together to
connect these local food hubs as well as
other participating Farms so that they
can distribute products together and
save Transportation costs they can
Aggregate and reach um larger wholesale
markets um they're learning together and
sharing best practices um so this is
another you know really exciting um
project that we developed just this last
year that we are continuing to help um
find funding for in the coming year um
the other one of the other uh things
that we do is we help to um we actually
do now coordinate the New Hampshire E
Local month activities um and we have
turned that over the last couple of
years into sort of a yearlong effort to
try to get the word out and communicate
and educate consumers across New
Hampshire about the value of eating
locally in our state um so stay tuned
for more information because August is
New Hampshire eat local month but as I
say we're trying to get the word out
that every month should be E Local month
here in New Hampshire
um another example of of a collaboration
that came out of you know the
relationships that are built through our
network is the New Hampshire farm future
fund um it's currently housed in the
chesher County Conservation District but
essentially these are grants this is
philanthropically funded at this point
um grants to land trust to work with
land owners on Farm viability planning
and conservation easements so often
times um in order to to conserve Farm
land um farmers and land owners need
assistance to think about how can they
um continue their their Farm operation
into the future so this couples um
conservation easement and business
planning um because we've talked so much
about research I thought I'd also just
um mention that we also the New
Hampshire Food Alliance applied and
received a core um Grant from the
University of New Hampshire so this is a
a grant to encourage collaborative
research um amongst faculty members and
also to connect research that's
happening at the University with needs
um in the community and so um our the
the topic was the food and climate
research Network so we're bringing
together researchers across the
university who are interested in climate
and Food Systems and how do we create a
resilient reliable food system here in
New
Hampshire um and the last um the last
example of of um collaborative work that
we're doing that I wanted to share is um
is also to let you know that we're also
thinking about collaborating and
thinking about the resilience and
reliability of our food system not just
within the boundaries of New Hampshire
but working together with other states
in New England so again we're part of a
three-year USDA Regional Food Systems
partnership planning Grant with other
Statewide food system networks that you
can see here across the six New England
states and we work with Food Solutions
New England as well
um to try to figure out how can by 2030
we produce um that we consume 30% um of
the food grown in New England um is
grown in New England sorry that 30% of
the food consumed in New England is
grown in New England by 2030 so over the
next few years um this grant will enable
us to think about setting benchmarks and
working together across New England
states um to really ramp up that local
food
production um and finally finally just
to say how do people participate we have
an annual Statewide Gathering an annual
um strategy Retreat we have monthly
Network cafes we were talking earlier
about meat processing that was the focus
Elena was at our um was one of the
presenters at our Network Cafe to talk
about meat processing in April um and
and it's during these conversations that
again a lot of this collaborative um
effort is is catalyzed and initiated so
thank you so much for the opportunity to
be here and if you have any questions be
happy to answer them thank you Miss Hae
we appreciate that uh certainly you're
connected with a lot of different groups
that we in the agriculture work with do
we have any uh questions from Miss
Hae looks like you might get off easy
[Laughter]
too well all right listen I want to
thank all of you that came in today and
presented to the committee uh I know
I've personally learned a lot and there
was a lot of great questions and uh
certainly look forward to hearing from
all of you as we go forward with things
that you know we as the committee can
help you with and we look forward to
using you as a resource too as we
navigate our way through the legislative
process over the next couple of years
and uh so thank you once again and I
appreciate the time that you've given to
the committee and I appreciate the
committee members for taking the time to
learn about the various things that go
on at UNH and other aspects of
agriculture so with that I'm going to uh
close the presentation and uh you all
have those who have to drive have a safe
ride home and the rest of you again
thank you and have a great rest of your
day thank you